Da fällt er weg. Das Chaosradio, das hat einen Namen. CCC, gleich Chaos Computer Club, heute Abend. Ausgabe Nummer 40, diese besonders bei völligen Computerlien so beliebte Sendung. Da der Kollege Johnny Häusler immer noch daran arbeitet, das Neugeborene so zu programmieren, dass Vater und Mutter irgendwann auch mal eine eigene Mütze schlafen bekommen, helfe ich heute mal wieder aus. Mein Name ist Meg Warbeck, ich wünsche guten Abend und gute Unterhaltung bei der heutigen Sendung, vor allem bei meinen doch recht naiven Fragen zum Thema. Aber ich bin ja nicht alleine. Das ist mein einziges Glück.
Nicht ganz alleine.
Wir helfen dir weiter.
Heute Abend vom Chaos Computer Club in die Sendung gekommen sind Tim, Hans und Andreas. So viel habe ich mitgekommen. Es wird heute gefeiert, wahrscheinlich ohne Sex, weil das ist ja bei Festplatten immer scheiße, wenn man das da reinkippt. Unix, 30 Jahre alt.
Genau.
Was geht es denn außer Sex nach?
Das ist eher eine Feststellung. Es ist nicht so, dass alle gerade total aus dem Heucheln sind und sich irgendwie digital betrinken.
Zum 25. gab es den einen oder anderen, der der Meinung war, er müsste einen Text darüber schreiben.
Im Prinzip sind sie sich auch alle nicht... Es gibt nicht wirklich so das eine Datum, an dem Unix jetzt geboren wurde, aber wenn man mal so 3, 4, 5 Texte gegenliest, was eigentlich die ausschlaggebende Tätigkeit gewesen ist, dass dieses Betriebssystem geboren wird, dann ist das in etwa vor 30 Jahren passiert.
Ein Kerl namens Ken Thompson hat sich da irgendwie vorgetan, oder?
Ja, unter anderem.
Also Richie, Cunningham, so diese Truppe.
Es hat sich da so eine Bande zusammengefunden, die uns was eingebrockt haben.
Genau, damals bei AT&T.
Die Musik, das ist auch wiederum typisch Chaos Computer Club und Chaos Radio, kommt diesmal direkt als Ampere-3-Fall aus dem Rechner, oder, Andreas?
So sieht das aus. Die Musik kommt von der Beta-Lounge, die wir hier mit recht herzlich grüßen wollen. Wir haben nachher auch noch andere Musik und wir müssen uns ein bisschen abwechseln.
Gut, also ein paar erste einführende Worte. Zu allem gibt es jetzt gleich, an dieser Stelle gibt es dann noch mal ein paar wichtige Hinweise zur Sendung. Die werden heute Abend immer vorgetragen vom Kollegen von der Festplatte. Ihr kennt ihn ja vielleicht, der Kollege Olaf. Guten Abend, Olaf.
Das Chaos Radio ist zu hören auf allen Fritz-Frequenzen, aber auch im Internet als Riello di Ostriem unter www.fritz.de. Morgen findet ihr dort auch wieder die gesamte Sendung als mp3-File. Ihr könnt euch einmischen per Telefon unter 033 177 97 110 oder über den WeChat auf der Fritz-Homepage.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollege Olaf.
Wir sind wieder auf allen Frequenzen zu empfangen.
Wir hören noch einen Augenblick in die Musik. Dann sammeln wir uns ein bisschen. Dann gibt es die Keule UNIX.
Wir machen hier von vorne bis hinten.
Das gibt ja auch noch andere bemerkenswerte Informationen.
Bis der Arzt kommt. Gut, dann bis gleich.
Musik aus den großen Weiten des Internets. Der Chaos Computer Club angeschlossen an eine große Runterladestation von MPEG-3-Files. Chaosradio Ausgabe Nummer 40. Mit Tim, Hans und Andreas. 40. Und mit Olaf und mit vielen anderen Rechnern, die keine Namen haben. Unglaublich. Es ist quasi auch Jubiläum. Ihr habt dieses Jahr, das ist nicht mehr fern, also das ist quasi das nächste Highlight nach der Love Raid. Ein großes Camp draußen in Altlandsberg, 6. bis 8. August. Und das, was ich gerade im Internet schon gelesen habe, unter www.ccc.de strich Camp, ist Zelten mit Computeranschluss. Großartige Sache bei Regen, oder?
Das wird auch bei Regen funktionieren, ob es irgendwie im gleichen Maße alle Leute so glücklich macht, wie durchgehender Sonnenschein steht dahin. Erstens wird es nicht regnen, und zweitens, selbst wenn es regnen würde, wir haben auch mindestens ein großes, also mehrere Zelte, davon ist eins sehr groß, das ist halt unser Hackcenter, ein schon auf dem Kongress der bewährte Einrichtung.
Was sind das für Leute, die da eingeladen sind? Sind das Leute, die echt richtig was verstehen müssen, oder Leute, die auch, weil sie deswegen offen sind, der Computermaterie aber vielleicht noch nicht so viel Ahnung haben?
Ja, ich denke, derjenige ist willkommen, dem es Spaß macht, mit Internet zu zelten. Also wenn man sich das vorstellen kann, dass man da sein Zelt hat und seinen Rechner mitbringt und die ganze Zeit Internet und das toll findet, dann ist man da glaube ich richtig aufgehoben. Wenn man damit ein Problem hat mit dieser Vorstellung, wird man vermutlich auch mit der Veranstaltung nichts anfangen können. Also für uns ist jeder willkommen, der vorhat, dort Spaß zu haben und welchen Level man jetzt erreicht hat, ist eigentlich egal, weil lernen tun wir alle noch.
Es gibt dort auch Workshops und solche Geschichten, wo man sich dann wahrscheinlich ein bisschen intensiver auch mit bestimmten Materien beschäftigt. Was wird da angeboten?
Also es ist eher so, also wir versuchen schon auch einen kleinen Unterschied zu machen zwischen dem Camp und dem Kongress. Der Kongress ist halt sehr vortragsorientiert und hat halt außerdem noch das Hackcenter und das Camp ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen ein großes Open Air Hackcenter, wo es dann eben auch Workshops gibt. Wir haben das Camp in Dorfbereiche samft vorgegliedert, das wird sich letzten Endes sowieso alles ergeben, aber es ist halt thematisch ein paar Sachen schon ganz gut vertreten, auch noch mal mit eigenen Zelten. Vor allem wird Kryptographie einen sehr breiten Raum einnehmen, da ist das Interesse auch gerade sehr groß und ist auch eigentlich, was die Politik derzeit betrifft, auch ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Thema. Dazu werden sehr viele Vorträge gehalten werden und es sind sehr aktive Gruppen aus den USA, die Cypherpunks und cryptorides.org, noch so ein paar andere Gruppen sind halt dort vertreten und wollen auch richtig was auf die Beine stellen. Aber wir haben halt auch einen Bereich, der sich mehr den elektronischen schönen Künsten zuneigt, wo irgendwie mit 3D-Ruhen gespielt wird, wo ein kleiner Materielgenerator ist und GIMP und diverse andere Themen werden dort ihren Platz finden. Lockpicking ist vertreten und dann wird sehr, sehr, sehr viel anderes, von dem wir selber noch gar nicht genau wissen, was es eigentlich sein wird, dort sein.
Wie dick ist denn die Leitung, die ihr da hingelegt habt auf das Feld? Das ist ja eine Wiese, ne? An einem See, Altlandsberg.
Ja, naja, also wir dachten uns halt, wenn man schon draußen ist, dann müsste man halt auch irgendwie Internet haben und da dachten wir, es müsste sozusagen schon jedem in etwa eine ISDN-Leitung an Kapazität zur Verfügung stehen. Das heißt, wir werden dort 34 Megabit hinführen.
Dann nehme ich aber auch an, dass man da jetzt nicht einfach hinkommt und aufbaut und sagt halt, gib mal her den Anschluss, sondern dass man vielleicht auch noch eine Mark an euch irgendwie zahlen muss. Das werdet ihr wahrscheinlich kaum alles gesponsert kriegen, sowas oder?
Auf gar keinen Fall. Also wir haben halt einen Betrag, den wir nehmen, der nicht wirklich alle Kosten problemlos deckt, aber den wir halt für zumutbar halten. 150 Mark für die ganzen drei Tage. Das ist im Prinzip eigentlich das gleiche, was man auf jedem besseren Campingplatz zahlt, nur dass es da halt kein Internet gibt und keine flächendeckige Stromversorgung gibt. Ansonsten sind es natürlich vor allem die Leute lieb, noch mal ein bisschen an das anzuknüpfen, was Andreas gesagt hat, wenn uns einer schreibt, ja ich bin aber noch der totale Anfänger, soll ich jetzt kommen oder nicht? Die Entscheidung kann ich dir nicht abnehmen, aber es muss einem schon klar sein, dass das Camp ist nicht eine Anfängerveranstaltung, wo es darum geht, das Internet zu erlernen, oder wo man irgendwie seinen tollen Computer kaufen kann, wie er auf der KOM wäre. Das ist es alles überhaupt nicht, und es ist schon ein Camp, was sich an Leute richtet, die sehr, sehr, sehr gerne mit Computern arbeiten, sich da bereit sind, sich da auszutauschen, vor allem Communication. Darum geht es eben bei der ganzen Veranstaltung, die Leute zusammenzubringen und dort kommunizieren zu lassen, damit was Neues entstehen kann. 6.
bis 8. August, Atlant Swag, muss man sich da irgendwie vorher anmelden, über Homepage oder so?
Es ist zu empfehlen. Also wir bieten sogar noch einen etwas günstigeren Eintrittspreis, wenn man sich vorher anmeldet. Wir wissen noch nicht so richtig, wie groß der Andrang sein wird, aber beliebig viele Leute können wir nicht unterbringen.
Irgendwann ist der Zählplatz auf voll, irgendwann ist es keinen, in den anderen Schluss mehr für alle Leute und dann macht es eh keinen Sinn mehr hinzukommen, weil man nicht mitreden kann.
Aber es wird ein großer Spaß und es würden einige Sachen dort sein, die man vielleicht so unerwartet nicht erwartet. Das wird wieder sehen, wer kommt.
Der Laie würde wahrscheinlich wieder sagen, Computerspezialisten können doch keine Partys feiern. Ihr habt bestimmt kein Bier, keine Drogen und so.
Das würden die Laien bestimmt sagen. Das ist das, was sie normalerweise nicht machen.
Okay, es gibt doch Bier und Drogen, also geht da alle hin.
Nein, die Koffeinversorgung wird sichergestellt sein.
Schlafen müsste er ja nicht. Aber es ist wirklich so, dass man sich in diesem Camp ganz normal auch verpflegen kann.
Genau, es gibt dort Essensstände, man braucht im Prinzip nicht weggehen. Das ist das Wichtigste, das Camp soll sicherstellen, dass die Leute nicht gezwungen sind, ihre Tastatur zu verlassen.
Oh, großartig. Das ist nicht länger als 10 Minuten. Das nimmt Festivalcharakter an, wo es dann auch eine Leisure-Launch gibt, wo man sich ein bisschen ausruhen kann und wo DJs auflegen. Oder sind das Computer? Das hab ich neulich mal gehört. Die neue Erfindung nach dem DJ ist der CJ, der quasi ohne Platten aufzulegen, als sich vielleicht wie Andreas einfach nur MPEG-3-Files aneinanderklebt. Ist das sowas auch?
Ich bin mir ganz sicher, dass so etwas auch vertreten sein wird. Wie gesagt, wir organisieren nicht alles, sondern wir stellen die Infrastruktur hin und wir ergreifen halt auch diverse Maßnahmen zum allgemeinen Wohlbefinden über Internet und Strom hinaus. Aber sehr viel mehr möchte ich da eigentlich gar nicht drüber verlieren.
Der Kongress, das Camp 6.
August, anmelden kann man sich über die Homepage bei euch, ccc.de und dann slashcam.html, da kann man dann irgendwie seine Koordinaten einhacken und wenn man überwiesen hat, wird das auch bestätigt. Und dann hat man sozusagen sein Ticket sicher.
Sollte man nur nicht eingeben, man ist irgendwie im Business oder so, dann wird es gleich teurer.
Na ja, was heißt für teurer? Wer der Meinung ist, dass wir da eine tolle Sache machen und uns dabei unterstützen möchte, der hat halt da die Möglichkeit dies zu tun. Wenn nicht der Meinung ist, der kann seine Meinung ja vielleicht auch irgendwann mal erinnern, nächstes Jahr oder so.
Und wir werden wahrscheinlich dann in dem... Was ist denn das dann eigentlich? Wir haben jetzt 30.06. Ende Juli kommt noch einer, ist die 41 in der Ausgabe 42, wird es dann nochmal einen Rückblick geben wahrscheinlich auf das Ganze, ne?
Ja, also... Was bei Chaosradio 42 passiert, da habe ich wirklich keine Mutmaßungen darüber anstellen, ob wir Chaosradio 41 jetzt vor dem Camp noch machen können, wage ich ein wenig zu bezweifeln, das wird sich noch zeigen.
Werden Fritz in Berlin, dann 102, 6.
22.30, halb elf.
Protest. Rund 250 Kurden haben in Berlin die Freilassung des zum Tode verurteilten PKK-Führers Öcalan gefordert. Die Demonstration in der Straße unter den Linden in unmittelbarer Nähe der Außenstelle der US-Botschaft verlief ohne Zwischenfälle. Gräueltat. Deutsche Kafosoldaten haben in einem Dorf in der Nähe von Prizren die Leichen von 78 Menschen gefunden. Die Toten sind offenbar Opfer eines Massakas. Derzeit untersuchen Experten des Hager Kriegsverbrecher-Tribunals das Gebiet. Kosovo-Konferenz. Die Außenminister aus 16 Staaten und Vertreter internationaler Organisationen beraten in New York über den Aufbau einer Zivilverwaltung in der serbischen Provinz. UNO-Generalsekretär Anan verlangte zudem den schnellen Einsatz von UNO-Polizisten. Unklarheit. In Belfast gingen heute die Nordirland-Verhandlungen in die entscheidende Phase. Zum letzten Mai versuchten die Premierminister von Großbritannien und Irland Blair und O'Hern im Streit, um die Regierungsbildung zu vermitteln. Unklar ist, ob sich Katholiken und Protestanten bis Mitternacht auf eine Entwaffnung der Milizen einigen können. Bilanz. Der Bundestag hat heute den Berufsbildungsbericht der Regierung erörtert. Danach gab es 1998 bundesweit wieder mehr Bewerber als Ausbildungsplätze. Für die neuen Länder will die Regierung erneut 17.500 zusätzliche Lehrstellen fördern.
Wetter.
Nachts nachlassende Schauer und Gewitter 16 bis 13 Grad. Am Tage aufgelockert und trocken 21 bis 24 Grad. Verkehr. Verkehrsmeldungen liegen uns zurzeit nicht vor. Fritz wünscht gute Fahrt.
Auch im Online-Stream. Vielen Dank, Frank Züge. Der Blumhund, Chaosradio-Ausgabe Nr. 40 mit Hans und Tim und Andreas und mit Meg Wabeck. Schönen guten Abend nochmal. Wir hatten uns noch nicht ganz entschieden, ob wir jetzt nochmal die Geschichte machen. Ich glaube ich lasse erstmal Olaf nochmal die wichtigen Daten durchgeben, damit alle Leute Bescheid wissen. Olaf, bitte.
Das Chaosradio ist zu hören auf allen Fritz-Frequenzen, aber auch im Internet als rielodios.dream unter www.fritz.de. Morgen findet ihr dort auch wieder die gesamte Sendung als mp3-File. Ihr könnt euch einmischen per Telefon unter 03317779110. Oder über den WeChat auf der Fritz-Homepage.
Ich finde das total großartig, Olaf. Man stellt sich den immer total als steifen Kerl vor, der sich kaum bewegen kann.
Erinnert mich schon ein bisschen an Sam im Pack 3. So sehr viel besser ist das noch nicht geworden.
Er klingt mellow.
Aber er hat immer noch so ein komisches Sirn in der Stimme.
Naja nun, das wäre auch ein Computer.
Was meinst du überhaupt mit mellow?
Naja, so reichgespült.
Früher der C64, Sam, der war so quack, quack.
Aber ich weiß nicht. Ich erwarte mir eher noch einen anderen Feinschliff.
Wie auch immer.
Vielleicht löst ja UNIX unser Problem.
Endlich mit Frauenstimme.
UNIX, das ist das große Thema heute Abend. An dass sich das, wie sagt man das eigentlich, bei dem Betriebsprogramm 30-jährigen Jubiläums? Oder hat das Betriebsprogramm auch ein Eigenleben?
Naja, bei UNIX ist es halt wirklich so, dass es nur so ein grobes Datum sein kann. Es gibt da kein Jubiläum, weil es ja auch mehr so eine Geschichte hat von in der Uni entstanden und ein bisschen dann rumgebastelt und das erste Mal irgendwie gebootet. Aber diese Daten sind halt dann doch nicht so genau festlegbar. Und es ist nicht wie ein kommerzielles Betriebssystem zu irgendeinem bestimmten Zeitpunkt released worden. Also kann man das auch nicht so.
Aber so die Entstehung war schon 1969, oder?
Ja, entstanden ist das.
1969 gab es halt diesen ersten Hack in Assembler, der irgendwie der Ansatz war, ein ganz neues System zu haben, was eben nicht das war, was sie bisher hatten. So einfach gedrungen aus den Umgebungen.
Naja, also entstanden ist UNIX ja als Anti-These zu Multics. Multics war eine Entwicklung in den 60er Jahren von MIT und Honeywell und noch einigen anderen Institutionen aus der Industriellen Computerszene. Und die Vorstellung war, man baut einen riesigen Computer, der überall verfügbar ist, so was wie das Internet heute. Aber damals hatte man halt noch nicht so die Vorstellung, dass man da tausend Prozessoren hat und überall und hier und da. Sondern man baut einen riesen Teil, an das werden alle angeschlossen. Und naja, wie das so ist, da haben sich die Bürokraten natürlich auch gleich dran mit vergangen und dann gab es da also Verwaltung ohne Ende und Sicherheit und Benutzeranmeldungen und Quotas, Disquotas und all so ein Mist und das war halt nicht hippie-kompatibel.
Und ein wichtiges Argument zu der maligen Zeit.
Na ja, das waren ja also die Leute, die UNIX dann gemacht haben, das waren halt so echte Computerfreaks, die wollten halt auch gerne mal Spaß haben mit dem Computer und das war in dieser Multics-Empgebung, in dieser ganzen Bürokratie-Geschichte nicht so richtig möglich und deswegen haben sie sich von irgendwo her eine alte PDP-8 geklemmt. Sieben. Eine Sieben. Okay, Sie haben sich jedenfalls eine alte PDP.
Was ist denn das jetzt wieder?
Ein Mini-Computer.
Hast du die Chöre, Hans?
Muss ja hier mal nach Ola gerecht werden. Damals waren die noch nicht wirklich mini. Mini hieß in den 60er und 70er Jahren nur Kühlschrank groß oder nur, naja, solche großen Kühlschrank. Das war mini, ja genau.
Der Computer war halt ein ganzer Raum oder auch mehrere Räume und...
Also jedenfalls diese Freaks um Cunningham, Richie, Thompson, die kriegten so eine PDP7 zur Verfügung gestellt, wo sie irgendwie ein Spiel drauf programmieren konnten und machen konnten, was sie wollten. Also da hatte jedenfalls kein Bürokrat irgendeine Aktie drin in diesem Gerät und sie konnten da tun, was sie wollten.
Aber die haben ja schon versucht, so ein bisschen diesen Hippie-Ansatz, den ihr da gerade angesprochen habt, irgendwie in diesem neuen Betriebssystem durchzusetzen. Also Zugang für viele Geschichten, asynchron laufen, viele Dienstprogramme und sowas alles.
Naja, wobei sowas ist natürlich dann mehr hinterher so entstanden. Also zunächst mal ging es darum, dass früher das ja so war, dass Betriebssysteme zu den Computern immer mit ausgeliefert wurden. Also das war mehr so ein Anhängsel. Und naja, die haben halt jetzt irgendwie einen Computer erst geschenkt bekommen und dann gesagt, da wollen wir jetzt mal was drauf machen und haben sich halt irgendwie was ausgedacht.
Also ich habe mir überlegt, wie sollte es überhaupt aussehen, so ein Betriebssystem, was das für ein Betriebssystem ist?
Ja, ja, aber im sehr kleinen Rahmen. Also die ursprünglichen UNIX-Ideen sind sehr simpel und einfach im Gegensatz zu diesem Multics-Horror mit viel Dokumentation und allen Features, die man haben möchte und allen, die man nicht haben möchte. Und so haben die halt gesagt, wir machen das ganz einfach und ganz simpel und programmieren das jetzt einfach erst mal geradeaus. Und was erstaunlich ist, ist, dass diese Ideen halt doch so gut waren, dass dieses System 30 Jahre gehalten hat. Also so schlecht war es dann doch nicht.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, dass Multics 1969 eingestellt wurde und dann saßen sie da und mussten Gekors verwenden. Und Gekors war einfach das genaue Gegenteil von Multics. Da gab es nämlich gar nichts. Und, naja, UNIX war schon so ein bisschen der Ansatz, die Features, die man an Multics dann doch schätzen gelernt hat, nämlich Timesharing, mehrere User gleichzeitig auf einem Rechner, Protection des Codes gegeneinander, Security und so weiter und so fort zu implementieren, aber ohne den Overhead, der dabei entstanden ist bei Multics.
Wie hat sich UNIX dann aus dieser kleinen Gruppe von Leuten dann entwickelt zu so einer großen Geschichte? Also gab es gleich eine richtige A-Version, die auf den Markt kam und alle waren, ey, geil.
Überhaupt nicht auf den Markt. Ich meine, am Anfang wurde es entwickelt in den Bell Laboratories von AT&T, wo halt diese Forschergruppen waren und eben aus diesen Zwängen heraus, aus denen Programmierer eben neue Systeme entwickeln, haben sie halt erstmal einen ersten Hack gemacht, den sie dann ein paar Jahre später auf einer PDP-11 irgendwie mal richtig an Start gebracht haben. Also mit der PDP-7 haben sie glaube ich diese erste Assembler-Version gemacht und auf der PDP-11 haben sie das das erste Mal komplett neu geschrieben und zwar in einer Programmiersprache, die sie B genannt hat.
Das war übrigens auch ein Novum an UNIX. Also bislang war es eben so, dass Betriebssysteme auch nicht so richtig ernst genommen wurden. Und Multics war das erste Mal, dass man so gesagt hat, also wir wollen jetzt mal ganz viel Energie in die Entwicklung eines solchen Systems stecken. Und UNIX war das erste System, was dann auch noch portabel war. Also was nicht mehr auf eine bestimmte Maschine und so draufgepasst wurde und wo nicht die Hardware zusammen mit der Maschine entwickelt wurde, sondern wo die halt irgendwie gesagt haben, wir schreiben Loter C Programme und der eigentliche Kern, das was maschinenspezifisch ist, ist ganz klein. Und dadurch wurde das Ganze eben auch sehr portabel.
Was ja damals die richtige Krux war, weil es so viele Standards gab und eigentlich irgendwie war nichts, da kein Standard für das verhandelt.
Na gut, das gibt es ja heute auch noch.
Na gut, aber ich glaube damals war es noch ein bisschen schrecklicher, wenn da so jeder nebenher entwickelt hat und eigentlich niemand darauf geachtet hat, dass man vielleicht auch mal so ein bisschen irgendwie...
Normalerweise war es, also am Anfang war es ja so, dass es irgendwie ziemlich schwierig war, überhaupt zwei Computer in die Nähe voneinander zu bringen. Also die waren typischerweise mehrere hundert Kilometer auseinander. Und wenn mal irgendwo einer auftauchte, war das natürlich gleich eine Attraktion. Ich erinnere, IBM schätzte in den 50er Jahren den Bedarf der Welt an Computern auf vier. Ich bin mir sicher, dass sie mittlerweile von der Zahl abgekommen sind. Aber es zeigt schon, dass es natürlich eine Weile gedauert hat, bis die Leute überhaupt erst verstanden haben, dass das nicht Maschinen sind, die jetzt mal erfunden wurden und später gibt es was anderes, sondern das was anfängt, wo ein Ende nicht absehbar ist.
Also da waren die Begriffe Netzwerk oder Lans oder so.
Kommunikation oder sowas gab es gar nicht.
Überhaupt nicht.
Wobei auch das mit UNIX anging. Die Vorläufer des Internets begannen auch Mitte bis Ende der 60er mit der Entwicklung und es ging alles gerade langsam los. Und ja, das fing auch an, dass die Leute, die auch in größerer Entfernung saßen, nicht alle nur in demselben Rechner, an ähnlichen Problemen gearbeitet haben. Und mit UNIX war es halt so, dass hatten halt zwei Leute bei AT&T quasi nebenbei geschrieben und es tauchte in den Businessplänen nicht auf. Und demzufolge war es eigentlich auch kein größeres Problem, dass Ken Thompson dann Bender mit dem Sourcecode von UNIX herumgeschickt hat, vorwiegend an Universitäten, hauptsächlich nach Berkeley. Und UNIX wurde dann halt auch an mehreren Stellen gleichzeitig weiterentwickelt. Oder also in Berkeley weiterentwickelt, wurde bei AT&T weiterentwickelt.
Welche Version ist denn nachher überhaupt rausgekommen, die sich dann verbreitet hat?
Ich sage nochmal die Jahreszahlen, ich habe in denen mich aufgeschrieben. 1973 gab es die erste C-Version und 1975 ging es dann los, dass die halt die Bänder verschickt haben. Das war dann die Version 6, die eben auf PDP lief. Und das wurde halt so im Uni-Umfeld rumgereicht, ohne dass da groß jemand drüber geredet hat. Das war halt irgendwie eine einfache Möglichkeit, an ein vernünftiges Betriebssystem zu kommen.
Wobei das dann ja wohl auch so war, dass sie dann gleich an den Unis weiterentwickelt haben. Berkeley hat ja nachher auch eine eigene Version gehabt, oder?
Na ja, es war damals mit dem Programm nicht so, dass man ein Programm nahm und das auf ein Rechner trat und es lief, sondern es war grundsätzlich damit verbunden, dass man große Anstrengungen über ein Unternehmen musste, um das überhaupt auf diesem Computer zum Laufen zu kriegen, weil jeder Computer ja verschieden war. Und ich glaube, zu dem Zeitpunkt hatten sie sich schon auf 8 Bitbytes geeinigt, oder? Aber problematisch war das schon.
Die PDP hatte noch 9 und deswegen hat sich der Oktalkod ja irgendwie bei C auch so durchgesetzt, weil sie das sozusagen berücksichtigen muss.
Die Internas wieder. Gab es da nachher Probleme dadurch, dass so viele Leute angefangen haben, ihre eigene UNIX-Version zu machen? Also Berkeley hat ja auch eigene Version nachher.
Was heißt Probleme? Also zunächst einmal muss man sich klar machen, dass damals eigentlich niemand benutze UNIX. Es gab das halt bei den Bell Labs und das war halt irgendein Labor, sicherlich ein bedeutendes, aber diese Software war nicht automatisch in der Welt. Ich meine, es war überhaupt noch die Zeit, wo gleiche Computer, die auf der gleichen Basis funktionierten, sowas gab es nicht. Es gab bestenfalls Modell-Serien von einzelnen Herstellern, die sich aber untereinander auch teilweise massiv unterscheiden und auch für die Hersteller war es ein riesen Problem ein Betriebssystem von dem alten System aufs nächste zu bringen. Also das hat auch alles unglaublich lange gedauert und diese Idee, eigentlich ein Betriebssystem zu schreiben, was nicht zwangsläufig für eine Maschine, für einen Prozessor ist, war einer der wirklich neuen Sachen.
Ich meine, UNIX war das erste Mal so, dass auch größere Anwendungsprogramme dann so im Source durch die Gegend gereicht wurden und dann wurden die halt angepasst, weil das hielt sich alles in einem vertretbaren Aufwand, was halt mit Assembler, also mit den vorherigen Arten zu programmieren und zu portieren einfach gar nicht vergleichbar war. Das war alles wesentlich einfacher. Aber durch diese Unis sind eben auch so Sachen passiert, dass in UNIX dann aus den Unis wieder Utilities reingeflossen sind, die jetzt zum Standard gehören, die von irgendwelchen Studenten als Semesterarbeit programmiert wurden. Da gibt es also reichlich Programme, die dann auch erst über die Jahre so weit gereift sind, dass man sie heute als vollwertige Programme auch so.
Heute nennt man das Industriestandard.
Also Industriesträngs sozusagen. Das hat bei vielen Programmen einfach richtig lange gedauert und wir sehen das ja bis heute, wenn wir zum Beispiel ins Internet gucken, da gibt es dieses berühmte Programm Sendmail, was irgendwie dafür verantwortlich ist. Mails in der ganzen Welt durch die Gegend zu schicken, der beliebteste Internetdienst und dieses Programm wurde von Eric Orman geschrieben und der war einfach Student an Berkeley und hat sich halt gesagt, ich schreibe jetzt einen Mailer und ich probiere das jetzt aus und das Ding war halt für eine PDP 11 optimiert, also total, also es ist auch total krude programmiert auf ganz bestimmte kleine Hardware und das ist jetzt halt so zu einem mega monströsen Projekt geworden quasi, wo jetzt also die Mail der Welt von abhängt.
Ist das der Grund, warum viele Leute sagen, also dieses UNIX ist eigentlich eine Geschichte, die kommt vom KGB oder irgendein Arschloch hat sich das ausgedacht. Das ist ja unglaublich benutzerunfreundlich eigentlich von Computerspezialisten zu Computer-Spezialisten.
Es ist hervorragend zu bedienen für eine bestimmte Gruppe von Menschen, nämlich Programmierern. Genau dafür ist UNIX gemacht und das muss man eben sehen und das ist auch einer der wesentlichen Gründe, warum UNIX überhaupt auch sich so lange halten kann und so stark widersteht, weil die Programmierer sind die Leute, die die Software schreiben. Wenn es da keinen Programmierer gibt, der für ein System was schreibt, dann benutzt diese Systeme natürlich auch niemand, weil es gibt einfach nichts. Also hat natürlich ein System dann eine Chance, wenn es für Programmierer angenehm ist und das ist UNIX tatsächlich. Also wenn man bereit ist, sich mit der Maschine an sich auseinanderzusetzen und das ist bei Programmierern nun mal so, dann ist das einfach mal optimal, wenn man alles prima kombinieren kann.
UNIX ist benutzerfreundlich, es sucht sich seine Freunde nur aus.
Guter, hast du jetzt schön gesagt, Andreas. Mich hat es da nicht ausgesucht. Was mich jetzt immer noch interessieren würde, UNIX ist eine Geschichte, die in einer Firma gehörte. Wie hat denn diese Firma das jetzt aufgenommen, dass so viele Studenten rumgehackt haben? Mussten die das dann also neu lizenzieren oder durften die das einfach oder gab es irgendwann mal auch Trouble dann mit AT&T, dass die gesagt haben, also so jetzt geht es ja jetzt nicht, dass ihr alle eigene UNIX-Versionen macht, sondern wir...
Also da gibt es ja die schöne Geschichte von von Linux. Linux ist ja eine sehr ähnliche Geschichte zu UNIX und Linux heißt ja eigentlich GNU-Linux und Linux heißt deswegen GNU-Linux, weil viele, also das, was man heutzutage so als Linux-System kennt, halt mit ganz viel GNU-Software entstanden ist. GNU-Software heißt deswegen GNU-Software, weil GNU ist not UNIX. Also GNU ist dieses... So und warum ist GNU not UNIX? Das ist die Frage. Die Antwort ist, in den 70er Jahren hat dann irgendwann die Marketing-Abteilung von AT&T, die also die Rechte an UNIX hatte, entdeckt, dass das ein Betriebssystem geschrieben ist. Plötzlich haben die das gemerkt. So und dann dachten sie, ah ein Betriebssystem.
Ui, was ist das?
Was kann man jetzt verkaufen, haben sie gedacht.
Und haben das auch gemacht.
So und das hat den Richard Stormen und seine Freunde am MIT irrsinnig angekotzt und deswegen haben sie halt dieses GNU-Projekt ins Leben gerufen, weil es eben genau, wo genau darauf geachtet wird, dass der Quellcode immer verfügbar ist. Denn AT&T hat natürlich, wie das eine richtige Firma in unserem Wirtschaftssystem macht, dann die Quellen irgendwie unter Verschluss gehalten und gesagt, wir verkaufen euch das und wenn ihr die Quellen haben wollt, müsst ihr noch viel mehr bezahlen und weitergeben dürft ihr die sowieso nicht. Na so, das war der RDR.
Ja, na in den 80er Jahren gab's halt echt viele verschiedene UNIXe, die sich so aus dem Original Source entwickelt haben. Jeder Hersteller hat also den UNIX Source lizenziert, hat viel Geld abgedrückt, hat jetzt natürlich seinen Source auch nicht mehr herausgegeben, weil die anderen tun das ja auch nicht. Und so entwickelten sich diese vielen verschiedenen Versionen von UNIXen immer weiter auseinander. Da gab's dann irgendwie SCO und dann gab es, wie war das?
Also es gab einen wild Wuchs.
Warum kommt denn eigentlich so nach Badezimmer hier?
Entschuldigung, ich habe gerade die Reglerkontrolle ein bisschen verloren, weil ich mich gerade gewundert habe, ob der MPEG-3-Player, den wir jetzt irgendwie da haben, auch noch eine Lautsprecher auf dem Computer hat.
Der hat einen, aber er ist ja sehr leise.
Ach so, ich kann jetzt hier nur nicht ausmachen. Man hört es trotzdem. Ich habe mich gerade ein bisschen gewundert.
Ach so, dann legen wir das doch mal ein bisschen hoch, dann klingt das vielleicht auch ein bisschen besser. Ja, ja, ja, lassen, lassen.
Nee, man versteht euch da nicht mehr, weil vier Mikros in diesem heiligen Raum...
Sagt mal im Chat, versteht ihr mich hier?
Ja, ja, nur wenn ich hier ganz stark Hand anlege.
Man versteht uns.
Hervorragend.
Vielen Dank. Also kannst du Musik anlassen.
Na prima, wenn man uns so gut versteht, dann können wir ja gleich noch ein bisschen was erklären. Also, weil jetzt gerade die Sache mit der Timeline da aufkam, wie sich das entwickelt hat. Also, ich denke, es macht Sinn, mal kurz den Weg, den UNIX so genommen hat, grob zu überschlagen. Also es fing halt an mit den Bell Labs. Dann geriet das an Universitäten, vor allem an Berkeley. Und ab dem Moment, das war eben so Mitte der 70er Jahre, haben sich da schon sozusagen die ersten beiden Wege herausgebildet. Einerseits diese Entwicklergruppe bei AT&T, die halt nach wie vor dran weiter bastelte und versuchte da ein richtiges Betriebssystem daraus zu machen. Das heißt sich dann die UNIX System Group, USG, und eben dann diese Berkeley Leute, die eine Berkeley Software Distribution aus diesem System gemacht haben. Und da kommt halt der Name BSD UNIX her. Die Berkeley Software Distribution ist sozusagen der Source Code, den sie mal bekommen haben, den sie weiter verteilen, aber eben als Distribution, sprich mit allen Tools alles beisammen, so dass es läuft. Und da gab es dann eben auch verschiedene Releases. Und so kam BSD ganz stark in alle Universitäten rein. Also es wurde natürlich nicht nur in Berkeley benutzt, sondern vor allem da eben weiterentwickelt, aber benutzt wurde es an allen Unis. Hat dort wunderschöne Systeme vom Markt gedrängt. Wie zum Beispiel die Lisp-Maschinen. Aber letzten Endes war es halt doch ein ziemlicher Siegeszug, weil es hat dazu geführt, dass die Leute, die sich eben für Computer wirklich interessieren, die Studenten eben spielerisch mit diesem System weitergearbeitet haben. Und dort im universitären Bereich entstand eben auch sehr schnell der Wunsch nach Vernetzung. Und letztlich ist erst richtig populär geworden. Also diese Idee des Internetprojektes, was es schon eine Weile gab, als eben TCP-IP geboren wurde, unter WSD UNIX implementiert wurde, dort das erste Mal wirklich lief.
Weil, also das Internet, so die Community, die Network-Community, die war eigentlich vorher schon da, und zwar mit den UUCP-Netzen. UUCP ist ja auch ein typisches UNIX, eine UNIX-Affindung, wie der Name schon sagt, UNIX zu UNIX-Copy. Lange bevor, also was heißt lange, aber doch deutlich bevor diese Online-Netze, die wir jetzt als Internet kennen, wirklich populär waren, gab es schon diese Offline-Mails. Also wo man einfach Mail schreiben konnte oder News schreiben konnte und die wurden dann verteilt. Und das war schon zwei, drei, vier Jahre bevor TCP tatsächlich verfügbar war, war das schon eine echt populäre Geschichte.
Aber auch das war halt unter UNIX. Also man kann, ich wollte jetzt eigentlich auf IP raus, aber ist ganz richtig, auch Computernetzwerke, also auch sozusagen diese contentorientierte Geschichte, also E-Mail und News, diese Systeme haben sich auch schon vorher unter UNIX verbreitet, weil eben UNIX auch das war, wo die Studenten rankamen, die halt auch ein Kommunikationsbedürfnis hatten. Und der nächste Schritt ist richtig, ist dann eben auch, dass dort TCP IP groß geworden ist. Und BSD UNIX war von daher eine starke Größe. Hatte allerdings immer noch viele Probleme mit den Lizenzrechten, weil eben sehr viel von dem Source Code ursprünglich bei AT&T entstanden ist und der Andreas ja schon so schön ausgefüttert, drehten da langsam die Marketingleute durch, weil die haben nämlich jetzt die andere Linie gefüttert. Das hieß dann UNIX System III, Röhmisch III, ging dann irgendwann über in UNIX System V und reifte auch langsam an zu einem ziemlich ordentlichen System, was sich nach wie vor eben was aussah, wie eben auch das BSD UNIX aussah, mit Shell und Kommandozeile, bloß es gab dann halt immer diese feinen Unterschiede, bzw. auch am Körner ziemlich massive Unterschiede, weil es waren eben zwei verschiedene Entwicklungen, die da vorangetrieben wurden. Dann wurde sozusagen UNIX dadurch, durch diese Verbreitung, sowohl im universitären Bereich, womit ja auch viele Experten sozusagen herangezogen wurden, und auch mit der Verbreitung, die eben UNIX bei kommerziellen Installationen hatte, unter allem eben auch System V, im Business-Markt populär. Das führte dazu, dass eben so ein System wie Xenix geboren wurde. Xenix war der Versuch, diese Features von UNIX eben auch auf einem 286er PC zum Laufen zu bringen. Das war ein Microsoft-Projekt.
Die haben dich da relativ früher eingekauft. Wie hieß denn das vorher, dieses Xenix? Xenix.
Ja, und wer hat das gemacht?
Na, Santa Cruz hat das gemacht. Das kommt von Santa Cruz abwesend. Und Microsoft hat sich da eingekauft, weil sie das interessant fanden und weil sie nämlich auch einen UNIX anbieten wollten. Aber das war dann, naja, sie haben sich dann halt auch eine Xenix-Projekt in Xenix-Linie zugelegt, die ein paar Mal verkauft. Und das haben sie aber dann nicht so wirklich verfolgt.
Na ja, später ist dann wieder eine SCO zurückgegangen und die haben aus Xenix dann UNIX gemacht und sind mit System V verschmolzen, während andere kommerzielle Anbieter von UNIX-Systemen eben auch auf der BSD-Linie fuhren. Also jeder hatte sozusagen da seinen Lager.
Es gab auch die Hand der World, die man dann umschalten konnte. Das BSD-Universum, das System V-Universum. Mit einem Kommando konnte man das System umstellen, dass es nicht wie BSD oder wie System V-Verhalten hat.
Eine Katastrophe. Pyramid hat das auch gehabt und Apollo und so.
Die Pyramid, die in der Seabase steht, die hat glaube ich noch so ein System drauf.
Apollo war das so darunter, war ein richtig gutes Betriebssystem und da drauf haben sie dann Country und Western, also System V und BSD drauf gehabt. War großartig.
Country und Western. Wie ist es weitergegangen? Gab es dann irgendwann mal wieder eine Versuch, das zu vereinheitlichen?
Ja, ja, es gab ja in den 80er Jahren, es war eine Freude. Sie haben die ganze Zeit immer nur davon geredet, wir machen jetzt endlich das UNIX. Wir machen bildende Allianzen, da wurde die Open Group. Alles unglaublich open, xopen, tralala open, also sie sind alle total durchgedreht, aber dass sie letzten Endes auch alle massiv an ihren Märkten festhielten und immer wollten, dass gerade die Extensions, die sie in dieses UNIX eingebaut haben, natürlich zum Standard erklärt werden, lagen die sich auf Ewigkeiten immer in den Hahn und es wurde nichts. Und Windows zog dann halt auch im Laufe der 80er Jahre irgendwie dran vorbei. Wobei natürlich UNIX noch einen ganz anderen Markt beschickt hat. Richtig durchgesetzt haben sich eigentlich nur Sun, HP hatte schon einen signifikanten Teilbereich von dem UNIX-Markt gehabt, dann eben auch spezielle Grafik-Workstation-Hersteller wie SGI, Apollo, die dann letzten Endes alle immer sich irgendwie gegenseitig gekauft haben und in noch größeren Firmen zusammengeschmolzen sind. IBM hat auch noch eine starke UNIX- Entwicklung gehabt, die ihr im AIX digital, wobei digital ja auch immer irgendwie noch ihr VMS gemacht hat.
Ja, die haben sehr lange gebraucht, um das ernst zu meinen und eigentlich sind sie da zu spät gekommen.
Ja, die haben sich ein bisschen was entgehen lassen. Vielleicht werden sie ja nicht von Copac gekauft.
Aber das war eine Geschichte, die sich eigentlich damals dann mehr oder weniger auf diese Workstations konzentriert hat und weniger auf PC Geschichten gelaufen ist.
Ja, also auch diese Xenix-Welle war nicht zu unterschätzen und hat viele Leute auch hier in Deutschland an UNIX herangeführt, weil das war das erste Mal, dass man erschwingliche Hardware hatte mit einem richtigen Betriebssystem und damals gab es ja eigentlich nur wirklich DOS und wenn man irgendwie Xenix und DOS verglichen hat, das war Tag und Nacht zwischen. Also es gab ja auch zwischen. Richtigige Treiber, schnell, wahnsinnig schnell, irgendwie die Zeichen fassen da, so wie dem Switch. Xenix war eigentlich wirklich cool, hatte so ein paar Probleme, die irgendwie durch die Architektur bedingt waren.
Gar nicht, könnt ihr denn sagen, was exakt war es, was damals schon in den Anfängen reingelegt war in UNIX, was letztendlich das Ding für 30 Jahre lang so ein bisschen auch zum Standard gemacht hat, also zu so einer Geschichte, die sich so erfolgreich durchgesetzt hat?
Also am Anfang war die Faszination von UNIX war Multi-User. Also Multi-User war einfach das grandiose Feature, wo man irgendwie Benutzer einrichten konnte und dann war man zu mehrend auf der Maschine und man konnte irgendwie chatten und Programme im Hintergrund starten und solche Sachen. Das war unheimlich spannend, das hat es einfach rausgehauen und da ist auch UNIX nach wie vor relativ allein. Also wenn man Windows NT oder so anguckt, das ist auch wieder eine Single-User-Maschine und dieser kommunikative Aspekt, der sich dadurch ergibt, dass man einfach ganz natürlich in die Maschine rein kann und dann da zu zweit drauf ist, der ist halt nach wie vor erhalten und das ist auch nach wie vor ein wichtiges Feature.
Wie haben die Jungs das denn angelegt, dass man halt, also gibt es da dann auch so technische Feinheiten, wo man sich heute noch die Zunge leckt und sagt halt, ey geil, das sind...
Also ich meine, das ist eigentlich letztendlich die Implementierung immer klares Handwerk, wenn man erstmal weiß, was man haben will. Aber was ihnen ganz gut gelungen ist, ist, sagen wir mal, auch noch auf relativ nicht-Performantensystemen schon im Grundkonzept verankert zu haben, dass es interaktiv benutzbar sein soll, mit anderen Worten, ich tippe Kommandos und der Rechner gibt es Antworten, und das eben gleichzeitig für mehrere Leute. Das wurde dann durch zahlreiche technische Tricks auch sichergestellt, dass es gut funktionierte, sodass Terminals zum Beispiel immer mehr Rechenzeit bekommen haben, wenn sie wirklich brauchten, sodass, wenn man auf eine Taste gedrückt hat, das Zeichen auch möglichst schnell angezeigt wurde. Aber es ist nicht nur ein Feature, also Multi-User ist das eine. Denn es ist auch ganz klar diese Open Source Community, die sich herausgebildet hat, die ganz wesentlich dazu beigetragen hat, dass die Leute viel besser Informationen über das System austauschen konnten und es selber weiterentwickeln konnten.
Also es ist definitiv so, dass UNIX zwar eine Menge Features hat, aber es durchaus andere Betriebssysteme gegeben hat, die diese Features besser implementiert haben, die sich aber nicht durchgesetzt haben, weil die Leute einfach an den Unis UNIX gemacht haben und in der Lage waren, dadurch, dass sie den Source hatten, das auch zu verstehen, was da passiert und dann natürlich in ihrer Firma in der Lage waren, mit Hilfe von UNIX Probleme zu lösen, die sie mit anderen Betriebssystemen nicht hätten lösen können. Und so hat sich das halt durchgesetzt.
Sie messen an heutigen Standards auch, was die Forschung im Bereich Betriebssysteme angeht, ist UNIX eigentlich eher ziemlich hausbacken und schon ganz schön veraltet. Es ist auch so, dass die ursprünglichen Mechanismen von UNIX heute gar nicht mehr so verwendbar sind. Und UNIX zwar noch im Prinzip so funktioniert wie früher, da gibt es auch ein paar ganz grundlegende Mechanismen, die noch genauso sind wie früher, aber die sind zur Lösung der Probleme, die heute mit UNIX gelöst werden, gar nicht mehr sinnvoll nutzbar. Das geht gar nicht mehr. Und insofern ist es schon teilweise eine ziemliche Hackerei in UNIX. Das sieht zwar alles erstmal ganz toll aus, aber um die tatsächlichen Probleme zu lösen, musst du Sachen machen, die sind einfach gar nicht mehr vorgesehen.
Werden denn Star jetzt mittlerweile nach einer halben Stunde über UNIX-Geschichte zu reden, auch schon beinahe wieder nach 30 Jahren bei dem Abgesang von UNIX?
Also erstmal haben wir die Geschichte noch nicht mal im Ansatz angerissen.
Und zweitens ist es, mischt sich das eh alles. Also UNIX ist here to stay, das ist gar keine Frage. Noch mindestens 38 Jahre durchhalten.
Kurt, ich würde sagen, wir machen eine kleine Erholungspause. Es ist nämlich mittlerweile 11 Uhr, da kann man auch noch mal schön Jingle spielen und spielen ein bisschen Musik. Wir sind im Chaosradio mit Hans und Tim und Andreas und McLeodick. Schönen guten Abend. Das Thema heute UNIX.
Das Chaosradio ist zu hören auf allen Fritz-Frequenzen, aber auch im Internet als rielodios.dream unter www.fritz.de. Morgen findet ihr dort auch wieder die gesamte Sendung als mp3-File. Ihr könnt euch einmischen per Telefon unter 0331 77 97 110 oder über den WeChat auf der Fritz-Homepage.
Das Chaosradio auf Fritz, 30.06. Tim, Hans und Andrea sind hier, wo sie eigentlich viele Sachen zu tun hätten, um ihr Camp, ihren Kongress am 6. geht da los, in Alp Landsberg, in der Nähe von Berlin, vorzubereiten.
Das Camp, nicht der Kongress.
Informationen, zu viele Informationen.
Zu viele Cs.
Das heutige Thema ist UNIX, das großartige Betriebssystem, das es mittlerweile schon seit 30 Jahren gibt. Wir haben eben schon ein bisschen so von den Anfängen quasi, das ist ja mein Computerzeitalter, sind die Anfänge. 30 Jahre ist ja unglaublich weit weg eigentlich. Unglaublich viel ist passiert. Schon irgendwie bis zu den 80ern gekommen. 90er Jahre.
Ja, jetzt wollen wir, also jetzt ist es ja so, inzwischen hat ja UNIX schon den Homecomputer erobert. Also es gibt jetzt jede Menge UNIX-ähnliche Betriebssysteme frei und ohne jegliche Source-Beschränkungen, weil eben diese GNU-Bewegung dann auch Früchte getragen hat und da verschiedene Gruppen auch tatsächlich vollständige Betriebssysteme geschrieben haben. Als echtes UNIX-Betriebssystem kann dabei natürlich nur die BSD-Linie gelten, denn... Aber nicht im freien Bereich. Im freien Bereich ist BSD ein echtes UNIX-Betriebssystem. Da gab es also in den 80er Jahren dann Bestrebungen in Berkeley, die Sourcen für BSD-UNIX, die Quellen, öffentlich verfügbar zu machen. Da gab es dann Leute, die so kleine Versionen verkauft haben. Und AT&T hat das nicht besonders gut geschmeckt. Also die waren dann schon voll auf den Trichter gekommen, wir haben jetzt hier ein Betriebssystem und wir verkloppen das und machen damit barbarisch Geld. Und der erste Versuch, dann ein BSD für PCs zu erzeugen, ist auch aufgrund der Lizenzstreitigkeiten, die es mit AT&T gab, dann eingestampft worden. Also es gab dann eine Release von Berkeley, die aber strittig war, wo strittig war, wer da für die Rechte hat. Und da gab es dann Rechtsstreit ohne Ende und da musste in einer Kraftaktion in Berkeley der fehlende Code nachprogrammiert werden, damit man wieder eine vollständige Distribution hat. Dann ist aber aus diesen dann freien Sourcen sind mehrere jetzt auch verfügbare Betriebssysteme geworden, wie FreeBSD, OpenBSD und NetBSD, die alle unmittelbare Abstammung in UNIX haben. Ich weiß nicht, soll ich auf die Details jetzt nochmal eingehen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht die Details.
Wir gehen immer auf die Details.
Ich schlage hier gerade eines der tollsten Bücher auf, was jemals über UNIX geschrieben wurde. Also wer sich wirklich mit UNIX auseinandergesetzt hat, wird es sehr zu schätzen wissen. Das heißt The UNIX Haters Hand. Das ist mittlerweile im Print vergriffen. Es ist ein bisschen unklar, wie es mit diesem Buch weitergeht, aber man sollte mal versuchen, da irgendeine Kopie von zu erlangen. Also hier steht irgendwie schon im Einband, Two of the most famous products of Berkeley are LSD and UNIX.
Also die zwei größten Produkte aus Berkeley sind LSD und UNIX.
Hat schon irgendwas miteinander zu tun.
Ja, also UNIX hat natürlich auch provoziert durch seine Primitivität und insbesondere dann halt in den 80er Jahren, wo dann schon also echt moderne Systeme so mit Maus und so richtig High-Res Displays raus kamen, da war UNIX schon eine sehr antike Angelegenheit und die Leute, die Programmieren richtig beschäftigt haben, die waren eigentlich schon gewohnt mit besseren Systemen sich auseinanderzusetzen. Also so diese ganzen Abkürzungen und diese ganze Benutzerunfreundlichkeit von UNIX, die wirkt auch auf Programmierer manchmal abstoßen. Es gibt also durchaus auch Leute, die programmieren und finden UNIX einfach voll daneben.
Dann brauchen wir dann LSD, um weiterzumachen.
Vielleicht gar nicht mal so, aber dieses UNIX-Haters-Handbook ist dann quasi so das in ein Buch gefasste Ergebnis einer Mailing-Liste, die damals eben, sowas gab es eben damals auch schon, war alles basierend auf Offline-Netz und USCP. Die hieß UNIX-Haters und da haben sich also die Systemadministratoren abreagiert, wenn ihnen das Thema wieder richtig die Arbeit versaut hat. Ja, aber es ist einfach auch so primitiv und schlecht in mancherlei Hinsicht, da kann man sich auch nur drüber aufregen. Also zum Beispiel, dass man UNIX-Systeme nicht einfach abschalten kann, sondern immer geordnet runterfahren muss und wenn man das nicht macht, dass man dann also sprichwörtlich Stunden vor der Maschine sitzt und sie beschäftigt sich mit sich selbst, bevor sie wieder bereit ist, einen Befehl entgegenzunehmen, dass es einfach unterhört.
Dazu kommt natürlich, dass durch diese vielen verschiedenen UNIX-Linien alles überall anders funktionierte. Also angefangen davon, wie ist das Kapitel, wie heißt denn das Print-Kommando diese Woche. Das Drucken kam halt relativ spät dazu und Drucken war halt immer ein Problem, weil es überall anders funktionierte und so zog sich das durch die ganzen Betriebssysteme durch. Auch die APs waren verschieden, also unter BSD funktioniert mit der Netzwerkprogrammierung anders, als unter System V, wo es dann Streams gab, die eigentlich eine ganz tolle Sache waren, aber auch grauenhaft zu programmieren. Und dann auch durch die Tatsache, dass relativ viel von dieser Software an Universitäten entwickelt wurde, zum Beispiel das grafische System, das benutzt wurde X. Es ist ja ganz hübsch, dass man das auch über das Netzwerk verwenden kann, aber die Anzahl der Funktionen in verschiedenen X-Libraries korrespondiert eins zu eins mit der Anzahl der Studenten in der Betriebssystemvorlesung am MIT.
Mein eigenes AP.
Also viele Sachen zwar da sind, aber keine wirklich zufriedenstellende Qualität erzielen. Also die Beziehung zu UNIX ist eigentlich durchaus durch eine gewisse Hassliebe geprägt.
Gab es denn in den 90ern durch die internationalen Weiterverbreitung des Internets nochmal einen neuen Schub für UNIX-Geschichten? Also gerade dieser Kommunikationscharakter hat ja nochmal UNIX weiter nach vorne gebracht.
Die Tatsache, dass Internet heute die Bedeutung hat, die es eben hat, nämlich einfach mal mit dem Anspruch, einfach mal das, die Plattform des Computings im nächsten Jahrtausend zu sein, ist im Prinzip ein Erfolg von UNIX. Heute wird das Internet im Wesentlichen mit UNIX-Computern betrieben. Die Router, die ganzen Systeme, die Mail-Dienste im Wesentlichen fahren, das ist alles in der absoluten Mehrheit UNIX. Natürlich gibt es auch irgendwelche Menschen, die der Meinung sind, man könnte das ja auch alles mit Windows NT machen, aber...
Da hast du aber glaube ich gerade einen Test von irgendeiner US-Teilschrift, die Windows NT und fünf verschiedene UNIX-Versionen getestet hat. Uns hat das gefallen dabei.
Das ist ja momentan auch so einer der Primärstreits in der Szene, ob Windows NT nun tauglich ist oder nicht. Viele der UNIX-Anhänger oder der Anhänger dieser Betriebssysteme mit X sind der Meinung, dass Windows also vollständig untauglich ist. Und sind da auch bereit, jeden Unsinn zu erzählen und zu postulieren, nur um diesen Glauben dann auch durchzusetzen.
Es ist Windows, es muss scheiße sein.
Genau, es ist per Definition totaler Mist. Und da finden jetzt die wahnwitzigsten Kampfaustragungen statt. Und Statements und Gegenstatements, Performancemessungen, ohne Ende, alles totaler Mist.
Man kann das halt einfach an Performancezahlen nicht festmachen. Das, was UNIX kann, kann derzeit auch wirklich nur in Umfang sieht. Und da ist Windows NT nicht dran. Windows NT sieht vielleicht mehr aus wie Windows. Und es kommt einem irgendwie toll vor vom Multi-Clicky-Effekt. Aber es hat halt alle klassischen Probleme von Kommerzieller, nicht freier Software.
Na ja, Windows NT ist the return of Multics. Multics strikes back.
Genau, also Windows NT verkörpert heutzutage das, wofür UNIX angetreten ist, zu besiegen. Ich denke, sie werden es auch kriegen.
Also 30 Jahre ist Windows NT dann zu kaufen. Das könnte in 30 Jahren noch von den Problemen machen, es ist so weit entwickelt. Gibt es denn heute großartige Unterschiede? Weil für den Anfänger, der sich ein bisschen reinarbeitet, ist es erstmal unüberschaubar, was es da alles für Versionen gibt. Gibt es da große Unterschiede? Also auch entscheidende?
Also man muss zwei Sachen auseinanderhalten. Erstmal gibt es halt im Prinzip derzeit drei verschiedene Varianten von UNIX. Das erste ist das BSD-UNIX, was wir nur ausführlich irgendwie besprochen haben, in verschiedenen Ausprägungen. Dann gibt es nach wie vor das System V UNIX von AT&T, was aber irgendwie kommerziell ist und sicherlich irgendwie seine Schwierigkeiten haben wird, ins nächste Jahr 1000 zu schaffen. Na gut, durch Solaris werden sie sich wahrscheinlich noch lange halten.
Entweder man kauft NT oder man kauft UNIX. Und wenn du eine große Anlage kaufst, dann kaufst du Solaris oder HPUX. Also jedenfalls eine große Anlage. Und der NT, da muss man schon ganz schön viel Geld von Microsoft für kriegen.
Nicht, dass es durch NT ersetzt wird, aber ich denke mal, dass das System V ist doch schon, vor allem mit FreeBSD und mit Linux.
Das ist nicht absehbar.
Ja gut, verschwinden wird es auf gar keinen Fall.
Er hat recht.
Gut, halten wir fest, es gibt halt irgendwie das alte System V, was irgendwie kommerziell ist, was irgendwie bei verschiedenen Firmen noch verwendet wird. Und es gibt die freien BSD-UNIX. Und dann gibt es halt diese dritte neue Bewegung, die man halt unter dem Namen Linux zusammenfasst, was eben das Zusammengehen von dem Linux-Könnel und dem GNU-Environment ist, was im Prinzip auch ist wie UNIX, aber eben nicht auf Southcode basiert, der aus der ursprünglichen UNIX-Entwicklung hervorgegangen ist. Und das sind erst mal so die drei Plattformen, für die man sich entscheiden kann. Und dann gibt es innerhalb des jeweiligen Systems immer noch dieses Problem mit der Distribution. Das Phil-Set ist ja ganz nett, aber nirgendwo steht auf einem Blatt Papier, was UNIX alles umfasst. Da gibt es dermaßen viel Software, irgendwie mehr, als man irgendwie auf eine normale Festplatte installieren kann. Also muss man irgendwie ein Working-Set haben, eine Sammlung, die eben das tut, was man eben machen möchte.
Vor allen Dingen die konsistent ist, wo die einzelnen Komponenten aufeinander angepasst sind.
Genau, dass sie auch eben miteinander funktionieren. Das nennt man eben eine Distribution. Dafür gibt es eben Distributoren, weil Linux populärerweise halt Suse und Debian und auch diverse andere auch. Man muss sich halt eben auch entscheiden, welche Distribution man nimmt. Aber man befindet sich halt immer im Bereich Linux.
Man kann natürlich auch auf eine Distribution verzichten, sein System von Anfang an selbst zusammenstellen. Aber ich denke, da sollte man irgendwie die anderen das so machen. Wenn man das verstanden hat, darf man auch seine eigene Distribution machen. Vorher würde man das wahrscheinlich nicht hinkriegen.
Das Problem bei diesen eigenen Distributionen ist, dass die oft ziemlich asozial sind. Also du kommst auf ein System und denkst, es ist UNIX. Und dann fängt es damit an, dass irgendwie LS und alles ist bunt. Und es gibt keinen Tipp. Und das fehlt die Hälfte. Und dann gibt es irgendwie die merkwürdigsten Command Line Optionen, die Editors mit farbiger Vorhöhung des Textes. Und das ist schon eine komische Geschichte. Wenn ich mir UNIX vorstelle, stelle ich mir halt immer so einen kompletten Satz vor und das ist halt UNIX. Manchmal ein bisschen kreblich, aber okay. Und unter Linux, da kannst du jegliche beliebige Überraschung erleben. Das ist also in der Art...
Also wenn man Lust hat auf ein klassisches, konsistentes DSD-Varianten anschauen. Auf dem PC ist FreeBSD gut zu empfehlen, aber auch die anderen taugen.
Wobei das natürlich immer unterschiedlich ist. Es gibt Untersuchungen darüber, warum es so ist, dass erfahrene User mit UNIX sehr, sehr effizient arbeiten können. Und ob es da vielleicht einen kleinsten gemeinsamen Satz von Features gibt, die das zu einem System machen, das für Profis geeignet ist. Und dabei wurde festgestellt, dass UNIX aus sehr, sehr vielen Utilities besteht und jeder dieses Systemen anders benutzt. Es gibt keine zwei Leute, die dieses System genauso benutzen. Und das ist eine der Stärken von UNIX. Und deshalb ist auch jede UNIX-Installation ein bisschen anders.
Das heißt, es ist auch für jeden User eigentlich eine Entscheidung, was nehme ich jetzt eigentlich? Was könnte ich gut gebrauchen? Und dann eher gucken, welche UNIX-Union ist mir...
Alle kaufen sich in keiner Wohnung gleich gefüllt und hat die gleiche Menge an Papier, technischen Geräten oder was man sonst noch so aus seinem Schreibtisch legt.
Bei UNIX ist es halt so, du machst irgendwie ein LS auf das Bin-Direktor, also auf das Verzeichnis, wo die ganzen Befehle drinstehen. Und da stehen lauter komische Befehle drin. Du kannst dir unter nicht einem davon was vorstellen, da steht irgendwie ARG und GREB und PS und SED und AVK. Es ist total unklar. Und dann hat man so Kumpels, die kennen auch schon ein paar Befehle, und dann benutzt man das eingebaute Dokumentationssystem, was dann halt auch manchmal auf irgendwelchen Installationen fehlt oder wo nicht alle Manuals da sind. Das ist wie ein großes Text-Adventure. Und man hat immer irgendwie, kennt man noch eine Ecke, noch nicht so genau und wenn es einem langweilig ist, dann kann man ein bisschen irgendwie die Manual-Page lesen und rumprobieren.
Das heißt, man hat, während man an UNIX rumpröpelt, immer noch irgendwo einen zweiten Rechner, der eine Internetseite auf hat, wo die ganzen UNIX-Tools alle erklärt sind, wo man sich so durchklegt, oder was?
Naja, also ideal ist natürlich, und so ist es auch nach vernünftigen UNIX-Installationen auch, dass die Dokumentation, die im System drin ist, ausreicht, wenn du ein Grundverständnis hast, für das System dich da durchzuhangen. Also das macht eigentlich auch die Qualität eines UNIX-Systems aus, dass man halt einfach reingeht und man kennt sich so ein bisschen aus und du kannst halt alles so nachlesen. Das ist eine gute Angelegenheit, diese Selbstdokumentierende. Wobei, man kann darüber diskutieren, wie viel Wissen du haben musst, um dich da zurechtzufinden. Das ist doch teilweise etwas hanebüchen.
Also es ist so, dass selbst Experten nicht unbedingt wissen, wie etwas geht auf UNIX, sondern ein UNIX-Experte zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass er in der Lage ist, eine Problemlösungsstrategie zu entwerfen und sich mit Hilfe der zur Verfügung stehenden Werkzeuge dadurch das Problem durchzuhangeln.
Gibt es eigentlich sowas wie den UNIX-Guru, jemand, der das seit Anfang mitverfolgt hat und sich wirklich extrem auskennt, den alle mal anrufen oder eine E-Mail schicken, wenn sie mal nicht weiter wissen?
Ja, der UNIX-Guru heißt Internet. Und man fragt einfach den Internet irgendwie was zu UNIX, und dann weiß das Internet auch eine Antwort.
Obwohl natürlich UNIX-Guru eine Zeit lang tatsächlich eine Berufsbezeichnung war, die auch in Stellenanzeigen verwendet wurden. Also es gibt tatsächlich, man hat irgendwann ein Level erreicht, wenn man in der Lage ist, jedes beliebige auftretende Problem zu lösen. Nicht, dass man unbedingt weiß, wie es geht, aber man ist in einer fest gesetzten Zeit in der Lage es zu lösen, dann wird man als Guru bezeichnet. Naja, das ist also so.
Bei UNIX gibt es auch verschiedene Ebenen von Erleuchtung, die du haben kannst als UNIX-Anwender.
Oh Gott, das ist eine Religion, UNIX.
Also dieses Guru-Level, das ist sprichwörtlich, und das gibt es auch. Und da wird also, das gibt Fragen, die erfordern einfach ein Guru, damit man sie beantworten kann. Das geht einfach nicht anders.
Sind Sie ein UNIX-Guru, zahlen wir Ihnen 3000 Mark in der Stunde, und dann fangen Sie uns einfach an.
Ich glaube, die Abstufung im Jargon-Fall war so, ein Hacker ist jemand, der die meisten auftreten, Probleme so lösen kann. Ein Wizard ist jemand, der sich auf einem bestimmten Teilgebiet hundertprozentig auskennt und jedes Problem lösen kann. Ein Guru ist einfach einer, der auf allen Gebieten alle Probleme lösen kann, die auf diesem Rechner auftreten werden.
Und dann müsste man wahrscheinlich auch relativ großen Kopf haben, wenn man UNIX drauf hat.
Da gibt es dann so Umbildungen und Umwidmungen.
Lässt sich denn ein bisschen was sagen über das, wohin UNIX in der Zukunft gehen könnte? Also wo heute schon Leute dran sitzen? Also ist Linux jetzt eine neue Geschichte, wo in der Zukunft mehr drauf kommt?
Na ja, UNIX ist eigentlich ein klassisches Programmierer- und Serverbetriebssystem. Das heißt, es war nicht für Leute gedacht, die man heute als Endanwender bezeichnet. Der Trend momentan geht so ein bisschen dahin, dass Linux zum Desktopbetriebssystem, zum Userbetriebssystem wird. Es ist so ein bisschen die Frage, ob das letztendlich miteinander verträglich ist, weil die UNIX-Philosophie schon die ist, dass man verstehen soll, was auf seinem System passiert. Also unter Windows gibt es eine ganz klare Trennung zwischen Benutzern und Programmierern. Und bei UNIX ist es halt so, durch das Command Line Interface, man gibt halt die Kommandos als Text ein und dann gibt man noch ein Kommando ein. Und wenn man diese beiden Kommandos hintereinander in einen Textfall schreibt, hat man schon sein erstes Programm geschrieben. Das heißt, die Schwelle vom Benutzen des Computers hin, dazu, dass man den Computer programmiert, ist sehr, sehr gering. Und bei Windows ist diese Schwelle sehr, sehr groß.
Kommt man eigentlich gar nicht rein, richtig, oder?
Das ist sehr, sehr schwierig. Also der Abstand ist sehr groß. Man muss sehr, sehr viel lernen, bevor man in der Lage ist, Vorgänge auf einem Windows-Rechner so zu automatisieren, dass sie bequem sind.
Und vor allem sind auch die UNIX-Installationen traditionell immer mit dem vollständigen Entwicklungswerkzeugen ausgeliefert worden. Das heißt, man installiert das System und dann hat man eben auch alle Tools dabei. Man tippt CC ein und dann hat man C-Compiler. Man kann irgendwie direkt sein Programm ins Terminal reintippen, drückt Return und dann läuft es auch schon. Also das ist ein ganz anderer Ansatz.
Aber es gibt nichts, wo man jetzt sagen könnte, da geht die Zukunft jetzt volle Pole hin, da setzen jetzt alle drauf.
Na die Zukunft, da gibt es ganz viel, was wir da nennen könnten, wo es hingeht. Aber UNIX ist mehr die Plattform, auf der das passiert. Natürlich wird sich UNIX auch selber verändern, aber in genau der langsamen Schrittgeschwindigkeit wie in den letzten 30 Jahren auch. Es wird nur mehr passieren. Also es wird mehr parallel passieren, weil es für immer mehr Dinge verwendet werden kann, weil Computer werden schneller, Programme werden komplexer und so weiter.
Inzwischen ist es halt auch so, dass jeder und zwar wirklich jeder Computer, den man heute kaufen kann, UNIX fahren kann. Das war so in den 80er Jahren. Da war UNIX als Ressourcenfresser und man braucht eine große Anlage und so bekannt. Inzwischen ist es halt wirklich das Volksbetriebssystem. Und zwar ist es auch noch das billigste, das kommt ja noch dazu.
Ja, ich würde sagen, wir machen ein bisschen Musik bis zum Kurzinfo. Dann können wir vielleicht danach noch ein bisschen weiter reden über eure Erfahrungen mit UNIX.
Vielleicht über die Erfahrungen der UNIX von Hörern.
Genau. Ich sage schon mal die Telefonnummer. 031 70 97 110. Läuft der Chat eigentlich noch?
Da wird fleißig gechattet, wobei meine Teilnahme begrenzt wird.
Deine ist gering, aber worum geht es da gerade auch? Geht es auch um UNIX?
Ja, um GIMP. GIMP ist super. GIMP ist ein tolles Tool, das unter UNIX läuft und nur unter UNIX. Ja, Photoshop als kommerzielle Variante.
Wir gehen gleich weiter ins Detail. Das Einzige, was hier nicht richtig ausfällt in diesem ganzen Chaos, ist immer noch die Verbindung zum großen Internet. MPEG-3 files, ohne Ende, direkt aus dem Computer hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz.
Wenn Brief an Fritz, dann Postfach 90-9000-14-439-HotStamp.
23 über 32-2-0-1.
Deutsche KFOR-Soldaten haben in einem Dorf in der Nähe von Prizren die Leichen von 78 Menschen gefunden. Die Toten sind offenbar Opfer eines Massakas. Derzeit untersuchen Experten des Hager Kriegsverbrecher Tribunals das Gebiet. Protest. Rund 250 Kurden haben in Berlin die Freilassung des zum Tode verurteilten PKK-Führers Öcalan gefordert. Die Demonstration in der Straße unter den Linden in unmittelbarer Nähe der Außenstelle der US-Botschaft verlief ohne Zwischenfälle. Unklarheit. In Bayfast sind heute die Nordirland- Verhandlungen in die entscheidende Phase gegangen. Unklar ist, ob sich Katholiken und Protestanten bis Mitternacht auf eine Entwaffnung der Milizen einigen können. Dieser Streitpunkt verhinderte bisher die Bildung einer Provinzregierung. Pilotabschluss. Die Beschäftigten des Berliner Einzelhandels erhalten ab August 3 Prozent Mehrlohn und Gehalt. Darauf einigten sich am Abend die Arbeitgeber mit den Gewerkschaften HBV und DAG nach zehn stündigen Tarif- Fahndlungen. Schutzabkommen. Der Bund und das Land Berlin haben sich auf ein Sicherheitskonzept für Regierung und Parlament geeinigt. Innenminister Schilly und Innensenator Wertebach vereinbarten, dass künftig Berliner Polizei und 1500 BGS-Beamte des Regierungsviertels in der Hauptstadt sichern sollen.
Wetter.
Nachts nachlassende Schauer und Gewitter 16 bis 13 Grad, am Tage aufgelockert und trocken 21 bis 24 Grad.
Verkehr.
Verkehrsmeldungen liegen uns zur Zeit nicht vor, Fritz wünscht. Gute Fakt.
Vielen Dank, Falk Zielke, mit dem Fritz-Kurz-Info.
Fritz präsentiert das offizielle Radioprogramm zur Love Parade.
Aufgedreht von TD1. Vom Love Parade Freitag 18 Uhr bis zum Love Parade Sonntag 20 Uhr.
Der Blumen hat noch ein Kürzel, was hinten dran kommt, nämlich Chaosradio. Ausgabe Nummer 40 am heutigen Mittwoch. Im Studio sind immer noch Tim, Andreas und Hans. Achso, den da auch noch? Olaf ist auch da.
Das Camp findet vom 6. bis zum 8. August in Altlandberg statt. Bringt Computer und Zelte mit. Im Chaosradio geht es heute um UNIX. Ruft uns an, 033170110.
Da haben wir ein bisschen Schwierigkeit mit der Telefonnummer. 031 70 97 110. Ihr könnt auch über die Fritz-Homepage www.fritz.de in den WeChat rein. Da ist Hans auch mit drin. Und guckt sich zumindest an, was läuft. So, ich habe jetzt auch schon den ersten Anrufer. Philipp, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Ach echt? Ja, einmal im Leben bist du immer mal der Erste.
Hallo Tim, hallo Andreas, hallo Hans, hallo Olaf.
Olaf, einfach mal Hallo sagen.
Mir sagst du nicht Hallo.
Du hast dich auch nicht mit Namen genannt.
Weiß dich doch erstmal aus.
Wo bist du denn da eigentlich da am Radius?
Mein Name ist Warbeck, ich bin Ihr Moderator. Ja, unwichtig.
Genau. Kann man UNIX sich aus einer Vollversion oder so wie UNIX aus dem Internet downloaden?
Ja, kann man machen. Zum Beispiel bei www.suse.de oder bei www.redhat.com und immer den Links folgen.
Unix?
Unix? www.freebsd.org.
Nein, www.urix.org.
Die Entschuldigung können wir dir nicht wirklich abnehmen, aber im Prinzip bist du, glaube ich, bei FreeBSD schon mal ganz gut aufgehoben, wenn du es auf dem PC zum Laufen kriegen möchtest. Vorteil bei BSD ist, dass die Distributionen sehr konsistent sind und man da eben sich nicht erstmal so viel über Distributionen Gedanken machen muss, weil da gibt es im Prinzip nur genau eine.
Und das hat natürlich Vorteile.
Philipp, bist du noch im Chat drinne?
Ich kann mich nur eins, entweder Telefon oder Chat.
Dann kann ja vielleicht Hans nochmal die Internetadresse reintun in den Chat und guckst ihn nachher einfach mal an.
Ich kann das auch noch mal.
Ja, du hast mitgeschrieben gleich.
Naja, wenn man tun was und dann nicht hat. Also von UNIX, muss ich noch persönlich sagen, hab ich noch nicht sehr viel gehört. Nur von Linux halt und von unserem sehr begehrten Windows.
Aber von UNIX noch nicht sehr viel.
Linux ist im Prinzip auch UNIX. Also das ist sozusagen ein Nachprogrammieren. Nicht ein Nachfolger, einfach ein komplett neu nachprogrammiertes UNIX.
Eine Frage hab ich noch. Da hab ich mal gelesen, irgendwie das Betriebssystem, das auf eine Diskette passt oder so.
Naja, es ist halt ein sehr kleines Betriebssystem, was spezialisiert ist, auf sogenannten Embedded-Systemen zu laufen, also auf möglichst wenig viel Platzcomputern. Und QNX zeichnet sich durch eine sehr schnelle Abarbeitung von kleinen Dingen aus und ist von daher für so kleine Computer wunderbar geeignet und braucht auch nicht viel Platz. Deswegen passt das Problem bis auf eine Diskette. Worauf du wahrscheinlich anspielst, ist, dass sie nicht nur das Betriebssystem auf die Diskette gepackt haben, weil wir da DOS ja auch schon mal drauf, sondern auch komplett mit TCP-IP und mit Internet-Webbrowser. Und das Ganze zum Booten. Also man steckt das irgendwie nur rein in einen PC und dann bootet das komplett in einen Internet-Kiosk hoch.
Naja, wobei QNX ist natürlich als vollständiges Betriebssystem so, dass es mit UNIX vergleichbar ist, genauso groß wie jedes andere UNIX auch. Der Vorteil an QNX ist, dass es eben auch UNIX ist. Das heißt, wenn man sich mit UNIX auskennt, hat man da eine sehr komfortable Entwicklungsoberfläche und Umgebung für Echtzeitsysteme. Dafür eignet sich das.
Muss man an der Stelle nicht eigentlich auch mal Prozix erwähnen?
Hier kam die Frage auf dem Chat, was der Unterschied zwischen den einzelnen BSD-Distributionen ist. Also FreeBSD ist die Distribution für Intel. Also wenn man nichts weiter als PCs hat und machen möchte in absehbarer Zeit oder vielleicht noch Alpha, dann ist FreeBSD die richtige Wahl. Wenn man eher mit alten Computern oder mit merkwürdigen Computern rumspielen will und irgendwelche Quellen für ausgediente Workstations hat, dann ist NetBSD genau die richtige Wahl, weil das auf fast jedem Computer, der so Workstation-Charakter hat, auch läuft. OpenBSD ist eher für die Paranoiden unter euch. Also das kann man so paranoid konfigurieren, dass selbst als Superuser an der Konsole da wirklich nichts auszurichten ist und man die Karre einfach nicht platt kriegt. Das geht bei den anderen WSDs zwar auch, aber OpenBSD ist eben von einem auch ziemlich paranoiden Entwickler federführend.
Sag mal, Philipp, wozu brauchst du UNIX? Also was machst du dann damit?
Ich?
Naja, ich bin ja so ein Mensch, der nicht von Microsoft begeistert ist und er möchte halt auch mal andere Betriebssysteme ausprobieren. Und deswegen wollte ich euch erst mal fragen, wo man UNIX herkriegt. Linux habe ich jetzt hier schon umzuliegen. Und UNIX werde ich mir dann auch noch aus dem Internet dann so rausholen, weil ich von UNIX speziell noch nicht so viel so gehört habe. Und deswegen, und das jetzt eigentlich heute zum ersten Mal so richtig höre, und deswegen habe ich euch gleich gefragt, wo kriege ich das her?
Also zwischen Linux und BSD, UNIX, wirst du erst auf den zweiten Blick große Unterschiede entdecken, weil das ist eigentlich dasselbe. Oder sagen wir mal, zumindest ist es das Gleiche.
Kann man eigentlich, wenn man, eigentlich ist es ja so, wenn man Linux neu draufspielen will, muss man ja seine Festplatte partitionieren oder halt eine neue Festplatte haben oder so, jedenfalls ein eigenes Laufwerk. Kann man UNIX oder auch vielleicht UNIX so laufen lassen, dass man halt nur eine Bootdisk einlegt und eher einfach nur von der Festplatte nicht die Windows-Informationen rausdauen oder laid, sondern vielleicht die...
Ja, so was geht. Vielleicht wäre es doch besser, mal in das Handbuch deiner Linux-Distribution reinzugucken. Das geht zum Beispiel bei Linux, dass man ein sogenanntes UMS-DOS-Filesystem installiert. Das heißt, da wird dann ein großes File in deinem MS-DOS-Filesystem reingelegt, wo sich dann das File-System für das Linux befindet. Also, GNU tut das durchaus. Es performt halt nicht. Es performt nicht. Es ist nicht besonders schnell, weil du da halt zwei Layer dazwischen hast. Es gibt auch einige Systeme, da kannst du von der CD booten. Da hast du ein sogenanntes Live-Filesystem auf der CD. Das heißt, du hast alle Tools zur Verfügung. Das ist halt ein bisschen langsamer, weil immer alles von der CD geladen werden muss, aber das geht auch.
Okay, Philipp, noch weitere Fragen?
Na ja, die Standardfrage stelle ich nicht. Die eigentlich nicht so. Ich hatte eigentlich vor QNX wollte ich wissen, denn Linux wollte ich jetzt wissen, ob man das auch nicht ohne Festplatte partitulieren kann. Mehr wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Dann wünschen wir dir noch einen schönen Abend.
Ach doch, eine Frage habe ich noch. Halt, stopp. Windows 2000, besiert es jetzt auf Windows NT oder nicht?
Wissen wir nicht, interessiert uns nicht.
Ja, stimmt.
Das ist eh scheiße.
Böse Worte in den Mund genommen. Schäm dich, Philipp.
Tschüss, Philipp.
Jetzt ist jemand dran, der sich nicht vorgestellt hat. Hallo? Hallo, ja.
Alex, hallo Alex. Ich hab mal eine Frage. Wo ist denn eigentlich der wesentliche Unterschied zwischen Linux und UNIX?
Wenn man über UNIX redet, es gibt eigentlich zwei Sachen, die man mit dem Namen UNIX bezeichnet. Einmal handelt es sich um Betriebssysteme, die tatsächlich aus dem Original UNIX hervorgegangen sind. Und da gibt es mittlerweile eine ganze Reihe Betriebssysteme, zu denen Linux zum Beispiel gehört, die UNIX-kompatibel sind. Das heißt, es gibt zwar ein paar Unterschiede, aber sehr, sehr wenige. In der Regel kannst du ein Programm, das aus dem alten UNIX hervorgegangenen UNIX läuft, auf Linux übertragen. Das heißt, wenn man UNIX sagt, meint man eigentlich in der Regel UNIX-artige Betriebssysteme, zu denen BSD zählt, zu denen Linux zählt, zu denen Solaris zählt usw.
Genau darüber reden wir auch. Wenn wir sagen UNIX, dann meinen wir nämlich alles das, was man gemeinhin als UNIX bezeichnet. Und das schließt Linux mit ein. Linux gehört zu den UNIX-artigen Betriebssystemen. So wie das UR-UNIX, was heute als BSD-UNIX verfügbar ist und wie viele andere QNX kamen zur Sprache. Man kann viele Betriebssysteme, die auch im Kern UNIX nicht so ähnlich sind, auf der Oberfläche immer noch genauso zu machen. Das neue Betriebssystem von Apple, das Mac OS X, das gerade in Entwicklung ist, wird auch auf UNIX basieren. Allerdings nicht auf dem alten UNAN, auf einer ganz anderen Entwicklung, dem Mach-Micro-Könne. Das spielt aber keine Rolle. Es fasst sich an wie UNIX. Du hast alle Tools für UNIX. Es laufen alle Tools, die du bei BSD-UNIX auch hast. Also es ist auch dazu kompatibel. Oder eben auch zur Dienung. Es ist ein BSD-artiges UNIX, was Apple da plant.
Wenn man selber plant, UNIX kennen zu lernen, jetzt als Oberbegriff, dann sollte man sich daran orientieren, was man für Leute kennt und wo man die meisten Informationen herkriegt. Das ist in vielen Fällen einfach Linux, weil das weit verbreitet ist. Und man kann sich ja immer noch entscheiden, dass das nicht der richtige Dialekt für einen war. Da gibt es viel zum Spielen und viel zum Ausprobieren.
Man sollte auf jeden Fall auch mehrere Sachen ausprobieren. Man sollte mal eine andere Linux-Distribution installieren. Man sollte mal zum Beispiel ein BSD einfach mal umzusehen, wo die Gemeinsamkeiten sind, wo die Unterschiede sind, was für gute Ideen es vielleicht bei anderen Systemen gibt, die man kopieren kann und so weiter und so fort.
Hier kommt gerade der gute Tipp, dass unter Linux im Allgemeinen UserDoc und UserDocHowTo die geeigneten Pfade sind, um nach Hilfen und Hinweisen zu fahnden, wie das funktioniert.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn das alles so gentechnisch zusammengehört, wenn man sich jetzt zum Beispiel einen Source aus dem Internet lädt, den steht ja oft als Kommentar da, kompelliert auf Solaris, sonst was, keine Ahnung. Wo ist denn da jetzt der Unterschied, dass es auf Solaris funktioniert? Weil, wenn es doch das Gleiche so irgendwie ist.
Naja, die Unterschiede liegen in den Feinheiten, in den Einzelheiten, wie man bestimmte Sachen löst, wie man bestimmte Netzwerkschnittstellen anzusprechen hat, wie bestimmte Dateien genannt werden in dem System. Wenn man irgendwie eine Anwendung schreibt, die eine Systemdatei sich angucken muss, zum Beispiel wo die User drinstehen oder wo irgendwas drinsteht, dann gibt es halt bei den unterschiedlichen UNIX-Versionen unterschiedliche Pfade, die man kennen muss. Dafür müssen die Sourcen häufig angepasst werden. Und es gibt halt dann noch so fortgeschrittene Features, also Sachen, die in dem ursprünglichen UNIX-Konzept nicht vorgesehen waren. Und wo dann die einzelnen Systeme auch unterschiedliche Wege gegangen sind, das zurecht häufig auch Leistungsmerkmale, die ein Linux, ein BSD, ein Solaris hat, was auf einem anderen System so gar nicht verfügbar ist.
Kann es jetzt zum Beispiel auch von Distribution zu Distribution abhängig sein? Also die eine Distribution im Dysverzeichnis, die andere Dys. Das könnte ja dann auch so sein irgendwie.
Ja, das ist auch so. Also bei Linux gibt es den File System Standard, aber da halten sich natürlich trotzdem nicht immer alle dran. Und das ist schon relativ konsistent. Also wenn man sich die Unterschiede zwischen verschiedenen Betriebssystemen aus der UNIX-Familie, zwischen verschiedenen Unixen anguckt, so sind die manchmal sehr groß. Und zwischen den Distributionen sind die Unterschiede kleiner, aber immer noch vorhanden. Also was zum Beispiel überall richtig unter High-Level-Konfigurations- und Management-Tools, also sowas wie Yast oder... SMIT heißt das glaube ich bei UNIX.
Super, SMIT ist also wirklich leistungsfähig.
Es gibt keinen Standard-Tool, um einen Benutzer einzurichten.
Genau.
Das hat sich einfach nie etwas durchgesetzt.
Manche Systeme kommen gleich ganz ohne Tools zum Benutzereinrichten. Da muss man dann irgendwelche Dateien editieren und Verzeichnisse manuell anlegen und so. Das ist... also das Gute ist, wenn man sowas nicht mitliefert, dann ist der Neuling gleich dazu angehalten, richtig dran rumzufummeln. Und das ist bei UNIX auch wichtig, dass man richtig dran rumfummelt und richtig alles ausprobiert und im Zweifelsfall noch mal von vorne anfängt.
Alex, alles da soweit?
Ja, alles. Martin? Martin. Also ich hab zwei Fragen. Zum einen kann ich mich zur Zeit noch nicht so ganz zwischen der Linux-Version entscheiden oder zwischen den verschiedenen. Also ich hab jetzt diesen Samstag gekriegt einen Server und der soll dann früher oder später im Rechenzentrum unterstellen. Erst mal in der Uni und später dann im kommerziellen Rechenzentrum. Und ich frage mich, welches System an Linux nehme ich da? Also ich hatte zur Zeit zu Hause mal eine SUSE-Version. Aber ich weiß nicht, da gibt es so viele Red Hat. Jetzt hab ich da zigmal in der Sendung von frühen BSD gehört. Wie scheinbar unterscheiden die sich denn? Ist es wichtig, dass da deutsche Autos mit bei sind?
Das kommt darauf an, wie gut du Englisch kannst. Also die Frage kann man einfach nicht pauschal beantworten. Zwischen den verschiedenen Distributionen gibt es ja auch möglich wäre, mit einer einzigen Distribution alle Geschmäcker zufriedenzustellen, dann würde es nur eine einzige Distribution geben. Aber es ist natürlich nun mal so, dass die Leute unterschiedliche Vorstellungen davon haben, wie so ein UNIX aussehen soll. Also bei Linux ist es zum Beispiel eher so, dass du relativ viele Features, relativ viele Programme, relativ viele Gadgets und Spielereien hier und da hast, und neue abgefahrene Sachen, die noch nicht so richtig erprobt sind, und die einfach mal zusammengewürfelt auf die Distribution geschmissen werden, eventuell vielleicht gar nicht funktionieren, wenn du sie direkt installiert hast. Und bei FreeBSD ist es so, dass da wesentlich weniger dabei ist, und da für die Sachen, die dabei sind, besser aufeinander abgestimmt sind. Also wenn du einen Server installierst, der als Server laufen soll, dann ist vielleicht FreeBSD das bessere Betriebslustergeschichte, das macht es sehr, sehr gut. Dafür ist der Desktopbereich nicht so ausgeprägt. Bei Linux hat man sehr viel Wert auf den Desktop gelegt, da ist dann GNOME und KDE mit dabei, und sechs verschiedene Datenbanken und alles sowas.
Spielkram.
Spielkram, genau. Also wenn du richtig viel rumspielen willst, nimm Linux, wenn der Server ein bisschen zuverlässig sein soll, nimm FreeBSD. Aber letzten Endes kann man beide dazu kriegen, genau das zu machen, was man will.
Ja, also als Serverbetriebssystem find ich ein Linux oder halt irgendeine Unix-Variante schon sehr geeignet, aber als ich zu Hause den verletzt hab, also hatte ich auf der ersten Partition immer noch Windows drauf und hatte auf der zweiten mal zum Spaß Linux, aber irgendwie war mir ziemlich schnell über, weil man so gar nichts anfangen konnte. Gibt's da irgendwie einen Emulator?
Ja, das gibt es. Es gibt jetzt ja neuerdings VMWare und VMWare ist ein kompletter PC im PC. Da kannst du wahlweise Linux in Windows NT oder Windows NT in Linux laufen lassen, was natürlich wirklich krasse ist.
Ist das eine Hardware-Sache?
Nee, das ist eine Software-Sache. Und zwar wird da die CPU komplett nochmal emuliert. Also im Wesentlichen läuft da ganz normal die CPU nochmal und alle privilegierten Befehle werden von dem Host-Betriebssystem, worin das VMWare läuft, abgefangen und eben auf eine Pseudo-Hardware abgebildet. Und da die Rechner heutzutage alle so wahnsinnig schnell sind, bringt es auch keine wirklichen Performanceverluste. Also es ist durchaus benutzbar. Es ist nicht so schnell wie original, wenn das System direkt auf der Hardware läuft. Aber wenn du zum Beispiel irgendwie gerne einen UNIX hast und für Spiel oder was auch immer, dann kannst du durchaus einfach das eine in dem anderen laufen lassen. Das geht schon durchaus. Das ist teuer, ja. Das kostet richtig irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, 100 Dollar oder 200 Dollar, jedenfalls irgendwie Dollar, Dollar.
Es gibt natürlich auch noch andere Emulatoren, zum Beispiel der Mensch, der Box gemacht hat. Box ist ein Emulator, der auch den Prozessor emuliert. Hat auch FreeMWare gemacht, also nicht VM, sondern FreeM. Und das kostet nichts, dafür läuft es nicht so gut. Dann gibt es einen Windows-Emulator, der nicht den ganzen Rechner emuliert, sondern nur die Windows-Befehle emuliert. Wo also einige Windows-Software drunter läuft, beleiben nicht alle. Das ist Wein. Und ja, ansonsten kann ich auch nur empfehlen, dir doch mal die Programme anzugucken, die es unter Linux gibt. Wenn du vor dem Problem stehst, eine Mail zu versenden, dann benutze vielleicht doch mal MUT statt Netscape oder ähnliche Geschichten. Einfach mal zu sehen, wie das Feeling dafür ist. Also UNIX funktioniert auch teilweise grundlegend anders als Windows.
Und es gibt auch Programme, die nichts kosten.
Weil hier zum Beispiel mit Schriftarten irgendwie so ein bisschen geklappt ist, dass du was da an Schriftarten mit KDE ballst, kann man völlig vergessen. Und wenn man sich zum Beispiel Webseiten in Windows angucken will, dann steht Linux da ziemlich hinten dran.
Das ist genau das Problem, warum wir Microsoft nicht mögen. Ursprünglich war nämlich HTML eine wohl definierte, standardisierte Sprache. Und irgendwann sind sie auf die Idee gekommen, da irgendwelche Fonts reinzubauen. Und aufgrund der Marktbeherrschung von Microsoft schreiben da natürlich alle Leute und wundern sich, wenn das unter anderen Betriebssystemen nicht mehr geht. Aber die Antwort ist ganz einfach, wenn du sowieso ein Windows hast, kopier dir die Fonts rüber, dann laufen die auch.
Also es ist schon so, wer mit Linux rumspielen will, der sollte auch mit Linux rumspielen wollen. Es ist nicht so, dass man das, was man unter Windows machen kann, irgendwie laden gehen, Spiel kaufen, starten, losdaddeln, das kann man unter Linux nicht machen. Aber man kann halt Spaß am Gerät haben, man kann sich mit ganz vielen Programmen einfach rumprobieren, ohne irgendwie irgendwelche Raubkopien hinterherrennen zu müssen. Und da sind teilweise auch Sachen dabei, die richtig Spaß machen, wo man richtig auch was mit produzieren kann.
Das war wieder alles klar, Martin. Viel Spaß beim Spielen. Es gibt ein weiteres Linus-Geschichte, hier ist Holm.
Ja, mein Vorredner, wollte ich mal sagen, sollte man nicht unbedingt probieren, mit den grafischen Sachen loszulegen. Auf der Konsole lernt man, glaube ich, am besten am Anfang.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Ja, da kann man immer schön so üben. Ich muss sagen, das macht sich am effektivsten letztendlich. So meine Arbeitsweise, die man so irgendwie im Laufe der Zeit entwickelt. Aber das beste High-Layer-Konfigurationstool habt ihr vergessen, das ist immer noch Sam von HP, muss ich sagen. Ich hab selten so geguckt, wo ich das gesehen hab. Das hat mich echt beeindruckt.
Ich hatte zum Glück noch nicht so richtig viel mit HP zu tun. Ich war dann mal eingeloggt und hab dann erschreckt festgestellt, dass das Ping-Vinery in ETC liegt. Dann hab ich mich ein Trocken ausgeloggt.
Ja, aber das war in Anführungsstrichen gemeint. Das ist echt, müsst ihr euch mal angucken.
Ja, aber man Smith ruht auch.
Kennst du den Smith auch von AIX?
Von AIX hab ich seitens zu tun gehabt.
Also AIX hat nämlich auch so ein fortgeschrittenes Administrationstool, wo du irgendwie alles zum Klicken hast, wahlweise. Aber der kann dir auch die Kommandos anziehen, die er ausführt, damit das passiert, was du da machst. Also User einrichten, kannst du irgendwie so Menü geführt, klick bunt und dann richtest du den User ein oder du lässt dir anzeigen, welches Kommando er ausführen würde und schreibst das in deinen Shellscript rein. Das ist richtig so, wenn man das haben will. Funktioniert überall und ist echt klasse.
Ja, das ist der Nachteil unter Linux, dass man sich das halt gerade bei Susi, die ganze Fasca, muss man sich böse durchwühlen, wenn man da wirklich mal was eigenes machen will. Und so im Laufe der Zeit muss sich URIX, Linux, krasch Susi, lohnt sich gar nicht. Weil irgendwann baut man sich das um, baut man sich das um, dann kommt ein neuer Update und dann sieht man völlig alt aus. Völlig andere Sachen anfahren, wenn man da mal Blut gelegt hat.
Das muss ich nochmal loben, FreeBSD erwähnen, weil bei FreeBSD hast du halt die Möglichkeit, das System auf dem aktuellen Stand zu halten, ohne die ganzen User-Tools und Utilities neu installieren zu müssen. Das ist insofern recht transparent und kann ich dann fortgeschrittenen Usern aus der Richtung auch empfehlen.
Ich habe schon gemerkt, ihr scheint sehr gern FreeBSD einzusetzen. Ich habe hier aufgrund von der Unerwartung von der Hardware, aber ich bin so bei Linux geblieben. Das fand ich so für Privatexperimente. Da kann man da viel drauf machen. Und so müsst ihr euch mal Unics angucken. Das ist so ein Tipp eigentlich. Da setzt die Suse drauf auf, da steht in dem Handbuch da irgendwo rum. Da kann man auch Luper-Informationen holen. Das ist ein Top-System. Das kann ich jedem Linux-Interessierten nur ans Herz legen.
Muss ich zustimmen, Unics ist cool.
Ja, Unics gefällt mir sehr gut, muss ich sagen. Damit arbeite ich eigentlich jetzt seit anderthalb Jahren oder so.
Das macht sau Spaß.
Gerade die Kompilierumgebung, die schätze ich sehr.
Ein zufriedener User, das ist ja auch mal was Seltenes hier.
Man muss viel lesen, aber da kommt man sowieso nie drum rum, wenn man effektiv was machen möchte, muss man sich halt in jeder Art... Jetzt endlich will man auf Netzwerk gehen, dann muss man halt die Protokolle kennen, dann muss man nur seine Tools benutzen.
Kommst du aus Kemp?
Nee, aus Berlin komm ich.
Nee, aber du aufs Kemp kommst?
Nee, nee, da war ich noch nie gewesen.
Kein Wunder, das gab's ja auch bisher noch nicht.
Ja, ich muss sagen, der Eintrittspreis finde ich ein bisschen hastig, aber sonst würde ich da gerne reingucken. Der 150-Mark ist doch, ich denke mal, ein symbolischerer Preis hätte es vielleicht auch getan. Ich weiß nicht, was ihr dann veranstalten wollt noch.
Also es ist bereits ein symbolischer Preis.
Ja, sowas veranstaltet verursacht durchaus Kosten. Ich meine, überlegt man ja, für 5000 Computer Strom, für 5000 Computer Internet, für 5000 Leute Kloß, Duschen und was da noch so alles dranhängt, die Zelte und...
Du möchtest es nicht wissen ab.
Ich glaube euch, alleine die Netzplanung für 5000 Leute ist nicht von mir von Hand zu weisen. Da hast du mächtig zu tun. Das glaube ich aber, ich hoffe, ihr habt Remote-Zugänge und so, dass man sich da...
Wenn wir haben, von außerhalb holen.
Das wäre schon optimal.
Das würde mir gut gefallen.
Der Sparmann holen.
Ja, auf jeden muss man ja sehen. Telefongebühren fressen einen Schnauf.
Wie viel gibst du aus im Monat?
Also weit über 100.
Naja, dann überleg dir mal, wie viel man in drei Tagen über eine 34-Mega-Leitung downloaden kann und in welchem Verhältnis das zu deinem Telefon geht.
Zwei Monate oder drei nicht online gehen würden.
Das kommt ja auf die Konstanz an, nicht auf...
Gibt da diese www.internetsucht.de, diese Fragestunde für den Internet-Sichtling?
Du hast alles daran beteiligt, ich hab das voll gemacht. Das hab ich vorhin auch ausgefüllt, das war doch sehr freundlich.
Du hast großes Psoz-Potenzial, Hans, oder?
Naja, nun, ich mach das so lange schon. Ich kann nicht mehr sagen, wie das zeitlich aussieht.
Freunde, weiterhin viel Spaß. Wir hören weiter in die Telefonleitung rein hier. Im Chaosradio.
Ich wollte mal ein bisschen erzählen, wie das tatsächlich so herkommt. Also, warum UNIX, also bei den etwas älteren unter uns, die das halt noch damals an der Uni kennengelernt haben, es einfach so richtig obergeil finden. Die haben halt damals diese richtigen Dinosaurierbetriebssysteme kennengelernt. Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, das war zu einer Zeit, wo es eben PCs praktisch nicht gab. Da kam der AT raus, der hat 10.000 Dollar gekostet. Da hast du an einem großen, dicken IBM-Rechner gesessen. Dann hattest du nebenbei bei Betriebssystemen eine schöne kleine UNIX-Kiste. Da warst du mit deinen Kumpels drauf. Da konntest du denen auf dem Bildschirm was schreiben. Wenn du dich eingeloggt hast, hast du geguckt, wer noch da ist. Wenn du Hunger hattest, hast du zum Beispiel Hungry eingetippt. Jeder, der geguckt hat, wer noch da ist, hat dann gesehen, wer auch hungrig ist. Sodass man sich dann zum Essen verabreden konnte. Nicht nur zum Mittagessen, sondern auch nachts. Und man konnte eigentlich viele Sachen auch mit der dicken EWL-Mails schreiben und sich auf den Bildschirm schmieren. Aber das war dann meistens in so großen Buchstaben, so Großbuchstaben, und so mit Alert und Wieb und so. Und bestätigen und der. Und bei der UNIX-Karre war das einfach minimal. So richtig so minimal. Alles war offen, alles war klein. Und du hattest das allererste Mal im Leben, du bist irgendwie an der Uni gewesen. Ich meine, du hast irgendwie aus allen Ecken und Enden was gelernt. Elektronik hast du gelernt. Und dann hast du Datenbanken gelernt und so weiter. Also aus allen Ecken. Und bei UNIX kam das alles zusammen. Da hast du dann das allererste Mal wirklich kapiert, von vorne bis hinten, so von der Elektrik, bis hin zur Benutzeroberfläche, wie so ein Rechner funktioniert. Und das war halt einfach das Erlebnis damals. So ein richtiges Drogenerlebnis oder Grenzerfahrungserlebnis. Also richtig so das kosmische Gring. Also wie so ein Kiffer, der sich irgendwas blödet anguckt und es geil findet.
Dann doch die Erleuchtung, eher religiös, oder? Fast religiös, dann doch die Erleuchtung.
Das ist einfach, weil du alles zusammengekriegt hast. Du hast irgendwie die große IBM nicht kapiert. Die war nicht zu kapieren. Da waren unabhängig dran, da waren irgendwie fünf Sysops permanent zu machen. Und alleine die Sysops zu ärgern, war schon so viel Arbeit.
Du hast es nicht kapiert, das Ding.
Das war einfach zu groß. Und die UNIX-Kiste, da diese 68.000 mit zehn Usern drauf oder 20 höchsten, die hast du kapiert. Und vor allem, es war halt eine geile Community. Du hast irgendwie deine Home direkt so veröffentlicht, in üblicher Weise. Du hast den Leuten auf dem Bildschirm schmieren können. Wenn dir jemand was sagen wollte, ist das eben breit auf dem Bildschirm gemacht, fertig. Wenn du auf einer Party gesagt hast, was du studierst, was studierst denn du? Und du sagst, Informatik sind die Mädels so von dir weggestrebt. Die anderen Ecken sind so im Raum. Das ist nicht wie heute, wo es dann halt, ah das ist aber toll, da kannst du mal vorbeikommen, weil mein Windows f*****. Ich kann nicht kommunizieren, die sind alle krank. So, so war das damals. So, und dann hast du diesen Kick an der Kiste gekriegt. Ja, mit den Kumpels, die irgendwie auf deiner Welle waren, nur die haben kapiert, was du da gemacht hast. Sonst niemand, deine Eltern waren stolz auf dich, haben es auch nicht kapiert, aber sonst passiert dir da einfach nichts.
Naja, das hat sich aber letztlich nicht verändert. Das ist so ein bisschen wie dieser...
die BN-Kiste, da waren Forschungsprojekte drauf, und so natürlich, aber die UNIX-Counts waren offen. Kein Problem.
Klar, Guest-Account ohne Passwort, alles lustig.
Aber alle Ressourcen...
Der Richard Stormy-Account am MIT.
Schwach dazu kam, also immer mehr, dann war ja dieser Informatik-Hype, dann musste ja jeder der Informatik studieren. Und erst dann, als dann die Leute dann irgendwie so einen kleinen Wissensforschung, den gab's natürlich immer, natürlich hat nicht jeder alles gewusst. Aber dann kam auf einmal auch die Arschkreigen, die dir dann irgendwie in deine Home-Direktorie einen File reingeschrieben haben, was du nicht schreiben konntest, und dir dann deine Quota weggeblasen haben. Irgendwann hat das dann irgendwie Splitz gekriegt, oder hat sogar irgendwo abgeguckt, oder hat sich's erzählen lassen, weißt du, und hat dann Leute geärgert. Und alle sagen, ja, mein Linux, pass auf, oder welches Linux soll ich denn jetzt nehmen, oder sowas. Das ist einfach völlig normal. Jeder hat einen Rechner, und alle wollen Linux haben, und alle finden sie UNIX toll. Jeder schimpft auf Microsoft. Das ist einfach Kultur heute, weißt du?
Hier gibt's noch gerade, hier gibt's im Chat auch gerade eine nette Geschichte. Die Informatiker von heute sind die Ärzte von morgen.
Das ist schon so. Du hast wirklich diese erste Ärzte- und Rechtsanwälte-Syndrom, weißt du? Wenn du auf einer Party dich als Arzt oder Rechtsanwalt outest, hast du sofort die Zuhörerschaft. Ja, du Bekannten von mir ist freundlich zugestoßen. Du solltest die Klappe halten. Ich erzähl das nicht mehr. Zwischendurch, früher hab ich's nicht erzählt, weil die mir so weggelaufen sind. Dann konnte man's irgendwann eine Weile erzählen, und jetzt erzähl ich's auch nicht mehr.
Also du hast das überwunden, ja? Irgendwann ist keine Weckerande auf der Party.
Der gute Tipp ist, dass man sich den Freund in deinem Dienst installiert.
Weißt du, wenn du auf der Architektenparty warst, sag's informatisch, und dann haben sie geguckt, oh, kein Architekt. Aber auch nichts Interessantes. Irgendwie war so wie Maschinenbauer.
Chris, vielen Dank für die heitere Mundeunterhaltung hier.
Ja, tschüss, Chris.
Mach's gut und bleib dran, Herr Doktor. 5 nach 12 ist das Chaosradio. Das Chaosradio am Mittwochabend, wie den letzten Mittwoch, im Monat, mit Hans und Andreas und Tim und Olaf. Olaf ist gerade stillgelegt. Du freust Hans die ganze Zeit.
Im Chat moderiert er Stefan Warbeck, nicht zu vergessen.
Ja, ich bin auch noch da. Ich telefoniere hier ein bisschen mit euch. 031 70 97 110 ist unsere Nummer. Und falls ihr diese ganze Sendung noch nicht mitgekriegt habt, zum einen der Hinweis, morgen ist das Ganze auf den Fritzseiten www.fritz.de als MPEG-File auch nochmal abhörbar. Und zum anderen, es ging um UNIX heute die ganze Zeit, Anlass 30 Jahre UNIX dieses Jahr. So, und jetzt hat angerufen Matthias. Hallo Matthias.
Hallo. Ich hatte einen Tipp für den jungen Menschen, der sich Linux drauf machen möchte, aber irgendwie die Festplatte nicht so partitionieren wollte, weil doch die Festplatte, wenn man die partitioniert, muss man doch erst mal einen Haufen Daten löschen.
Eigentlich.
Aber da gibt es bei Linux ein Programm unter dos-utils-fips, das heißt auch Fips.
Fips, F-I-P-S-Fips.
Genau. Und, ah, kennt ihr das? Wieso habt ihr das nicht als Tipp ihm gegeben?
Weil wir ja nicht alle guten Tipps kennen.
Ich meine, man kennt zwar Fips, aber das ist ein guter Tipp, das sagst du jetzt.
Ja klar, dieses Programm kann er verwenden. Das gibt es jetzt auch als neuen Linux, auch als In-Nord-Variante, sodass man auch Fips sein kann. 30 Systeme, damit neu partitionieren kann, ohne die Daten zu löschen.
Man kann damit also auch Partitionen verkleinern und nachträglich einfach noch ein bisschen Platz für eine UNIX-Partition machen oder hinterher auch wieder größer machen. Also ist es sowas, wenn man wirklich haben.
Ja, wobei man kann auch ganz simpel das wieder zurück machen, weil man steckt und das wird eine ganz kleine Datei aufgespeichert, die speichert Bootsektor-Information der Festplatte.
Ich meine, das ist eben das Gute an FIPS, dass es umsonst ist. Es gibt auch kommerzielle Tools wie Partition Magic oder so, die genau das Gleiche tun, aber FIPS ist...
fipssearch.likos.com Wie hieß es?
Ach, das haben wir jetzt natürlich nicht gesagt.
Also ich trage mich mit dem Bedanken. Es gibt ja nun seit einiger Zeit, also seit ein paar Monaten, so viel wie ich weiß, Solaris für Intel-PCs.
Wird das super?
Ja, ausprobieren ist völlig in Ordnung, ob du da so viel Spaß mit haben wirst.
Also ich denke mal, als erstes UNIX sollte man es vielleicht nicht installieren, aber wenn man schon ein bisschen Erfahrung mit UNIX hat, sollte man sich es durchaus mal angucken, weil es sehr viele interessante Ideen gibt und sich auch einfach mal ganz anders anfühlt als so Yet another Linux.
Ja, ich habe hier SUSE 6.0 zu laufen und hatte schon mal angefangen mit SUSE 4.1 oder 4.2 oder so. Das ist schon, aber das könnte mich mal reizen, das mal auszuprobieren.
Also Solaris ist ziemlich klasse, weil es, also das verdient nun wirklich den Namen UNIX. Im Gegensatz zu auch BSD oder Linux ist Solaris auch mit dem Originalmarken, echten UNIX vollständig ausgestattet. Und du hast das, so die Features von dem System auch recht gut. Also ich finde Solaris ist eins der besseren, echten UNIX.
Definitiv auch von den kommerziellen eigentlich das beste, das sympathischste.
Das kann man sich besorgen bei Sun natürlich.
Und kostet auch nichts für privaten Anwender?
Nee, 35 Dollar wollen sie haben.
Naja gut, das sind die Medienkosten. Also bei Solaris ist es so, dass es für den Privatgebrauch einfach mal kopierbar ist. Da braucht man sich keinen großen Kopf zu machen, da wird man nicht verfolgt wie bei Microsoft, sondern man kann es eben einfach benutzen.
Ja, das ist natürlich klar. Okay, dann werde ich das mal ausprobieren. Das könnte mich schon mal reizen.
Gut, Wolfgang. Schönen Abend noch. Tschüss und viel Spaß weiter mit der Sendung.
Eine Frage stellen zu Xenix. Könnt ihr da mal was drüber erzählen und was davon zu halten ist, dass jetzt alle Leute, die Xenix angewendet haben, plötzlich auf Windows-Netzwerke umsteigen?
Also Xenix war der klägliche Versuch von Siemens, irgendwie mit einem eigenen UNIX-System im Markt irgendwie Fuß zu fassen. Es waren mehrere Systeme gleichzeitig. Sie haben, glaube ich, ursprünglich mit einem eigenen probiert. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was das erste Xenix war. Auf jeden Fall dauert es dann nicht lange. Und dann war das irgendwie SCO-UNIX. Irgendwann wurde also sozusagen SCO-UNIX gelabelt, als Xenix verkauft mit den Siemens-Computer. Das war, glaube ich, der letzte Schritt.
Da gab es noch irgendeiner zwischen.
Auf jeden Fall war das alles immer maßlos, inkonsistent und schräg.
Xenix ist vor allem kein Betriebssystem, sondern Xenix ist nur ein Markenzeichen von Siemens für Siemens. Aber man kann nicht wirklich sagen, es gibt das Xenix, sondern es gibt da verschiedene Abarten. Und ob es momentan akzeptabel ist, vermag ich so nicht zu sagen.
Also ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass einige Versionen von Xenix noch schlimmer als ein NT-Server sind.
Also es gibt bestimmt gute Gründe. Zumal, wenn man sich dreimal von Siemens neue Hardware und ein neues Xenix verkaufen hat, verkaufen lassen und jedes Mal was vollständig anderes bekommen hat, dann hat man irgendwann genug davon.
Auf jeden Fall hat mich erstaunt, dass in den Copyright-Meldungen, ich habe nämlich ein paar Jahre mit einem Xenix gearbeitet, in den Copyright-Meldungen stand Microsoft mit dabei.
Naja, das liegt daran, weil Microsoft eben an Xenix mal stark beteiligt war und Siemens auch mal Xenix lizenziert hat und dann wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Utilities mal rein.
Aber SEO steht ja auch Microsoft.
Ja klar, SEO ist ja Santa Cruz war ja ursprünglich.
Hast du auch so eine Xenix-Geschichte laufen?
Nee, nee, zu Hause nicht, aber ich habe mal ein paar Jahre damit gearbeitet und in einer staatlichen Vermessung mit Xenix und da hatte keiner Ahnung von dem System. die Meldung auf You Have Mail und keiner musste damit was anzufangen. Und das auf Xenix.
Ja, also auch scheiß Erfahrungen mit dem Ding. Timo, bist du ein echter Computerfreak?
Fast, ja, aber Linux habe ich noch nicht, wenn es darum geht.
Vielleicht solltest du vom 6. bis 8. August zum Camp gehen. Hast du davon gehört?
Ich habe davon gehört, aber ich denke, das wird mir zu teuer sein.
130 Mark, Mensch.
Da muss ja niemand überreden.
Mit dem Slashcamp. Vielen Dank, Timo. Tim, du hast noch eine weitere Geschichte, eine Veranstaltung in diesem Fall, die du noch mal verbreiten wolltest.
Wer sich mit Betriebssystemen an sich gerne beschäftigt und auch den Philosophien, die jetzt im Prinzip aufkommen, gerade was so Lizenzierungen betrifft, der Einfluss von Open Source auf die Wirtschaft, auf die Gesellschaft, inwieweit das Ganze auch in sich neue Konzepte vielleicht mit sich trägt für die zukünftige Entwicklung von was auch immer. Der Markt vielleicht am 16. und 17. Juli hier in Berlin auf eine Veranstaltung gehen im, wo darf das noch gleich, im Haus der Kulturbundesprogramm. Unter anderem wird dort auch Richard Stolman auftreten. Richard Stolman ist sehr bekannt in der Internet-Szene, weil er derjenige ist, er kam heute schon mal zur Sprache, der dieses GNU-Projekt gestartet hat und sich sehr verdient gemacht hat eigentlich um diese Welt, weil er eben doch einige sehr wichtige Tools beigetragen hat. Einerseits natürlich den GNU C-Compiler, mit dem irgendwie alles kombiniert wird heutzutage. EMAX vor allem den super intelligenten Editor.
Also genau genommen ist EMAX ein Betriebssystem, das sich als Editor ausgibt, aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Richtig. Diese Veranstaltung ist wie gesagt am 16. und 17.
Juli.
Man zahlt da unter www.micro mit kmicro.org, kann man sich darüber informieren. Und dort sind auch links auf diese Wizard auf Ausveranstaltung.
Ich habe immer eine Frage zu den Veranstaltungen und zum Camp. Wenn man da jetzt nicht die drei Tage entkommen will, sondern einfach mal nur vorbeigucken will und ein paar Leute kennenlernen will, und so weiter und so fort kann man auch vorbeikommen.
Wir haben nur Dauerkarten. Also das Camp ist sozusagen für Dauerkarten.
Wir schlafen die Gesellschaft in praktisch, ja.
Die ist nicht geschlossen, da kann schon jeder hinkommen.
Aber wir wollen halt da keinen Tagesbetrieb draus machen mit irgendwie angucken, sondern zuzulassen, wer da rein will, der muss da halt irgendwie durch die Kasse durch und der Preis ist 150 Mark.
Alles klar, weiß ich Bescheid. Ja, denn Erfahrungen zu Betriebssystemen, zu UNIX, ich hab seit Anfang des Jahres, seit Februar, das Linux von Suze, weil ich so ein bisschen rumprogrammiert habe und da mit dem Doff und mit dem Tohopascal nicht mehr so zufrieden war und wo man was anderes ausprobieren wollte, dann hab ich dann C++ und Femlam und Linux versucht und das war schon ziemlich spannend, weil da ein bisschen anders ist und spannend fand ich auch die ganze Sache, diese Dokumentation zum System selber und zu den ganzen Tools, die man da hat, deshalb bin ich da auch noch nicht so sehr weitergekommen mit der ganzen Programmierung.
Das erfordert schon einen gewissen Leidenswillen, mit UNIX irgendwie produktiv zu sein, oder mit UNIX generell produktiv zu sein. Man muss schon Zeit mitbringen, sonst scheitert man halt an den Hürden.
Und jetzt mal so, geht jetzt vielleicht schon ein bisschen zu tief, aber so eine Frage, so einen Gerätetreiber da zu schreiben für die Soundcard, der bestimmte Befehle unterstützt, der mir nur diese ganz simple Sachen, nur einen AD-Wandler dann bereitstellt oder so, das wird mit großen Schwierigkeiten verbunden. Ich habe da schon mal ein bisschen was geguckt, da gibt es ja noch die relativ einfach.
Fast alle UNIX haben eine Schnittstelle, mit der man aus einem normalen Benutzermodus-Programm, solange es als Root läuft, also als voll privilegierter Benutzer, auf die Hardware zugreifen kann. Da braucht man gar keinen Treiber zu schreiben. Treiber empfehlen sich halt nur, wenn du richtige Echtzeiteigenschaften tatsächlich brauchst.
Naja, ich sehe das natürlich ein bisschen anders, weil aus einem User-Programm auf Hardware zuzugreifen, natürlich immer ein Weg am Betriebssystem vorbei geschmuggelt ist. Also wenn du das für eine spezielle Anwendung hast, die nur du hast oder nur zum Rumspielen, ist das okay. Und ansonsten, wenn du es rausgeben willst, wenn andere Leute damit arbeiten sollen, dann ist es schon sinnvoll, einen richtigen Treiber zu schreiben. Im UNIX-Könne.
Ja, aber das Problem ist, wenn du tatsächlich nur was für dich machen willst, dann ist Treiber-Programmierung, Treiber-Programmierung, was jetzt gerade wo ist und da willst du halt... Das geht aber schon.
Treiber unter einem UNIX-Entwickeln ist auf jeden Fall einfacher als das unter anderen Betriebssystemen zu tun. Wenn du ein bisschen mehr Zeit hast, kannst du erst mal angucken. Vielleicht findest du es ja auch spannend. Vielleicht willst du ein bisschen ein Problem lösen. Dann IO-Perm heißt glaube ich der Befehl.
Na und IO-Perm.
Genau, die beiden Sachen.
Ja, ich habe das schon gefunden. Ich bin dann auch wieder stehengeblieben. Da kommt man ab und zu mal nicht dazu und so weiter. Das wäre mir ja so ein Hobby da. Ich wollte da mal so ein bisschen Sprache analysieren über die Soundkarte und über... Na ja, und da wollte ich da nicht mehr weitermachen. Ich habe da so ein paar Signale schon analysiert.
Gibt es denn keinen Treiber für deine Soundkarte oder ist die selber gebaut?
Nee, die ist nicht selber gebaut.
Ja, aber ich meine zum Beispiel, um die Soundkarte auszulesen, da empfiehlt es sich doch einfach, Dev-Audio aufzumachen und da deine Bites rauszulesen. Da hast du überhaupt gar keinen Aufwand mit und kannst die Sprache analysieren.
Und da in dem Verzeichnisbaum, die weiße?
Du machst einfach die Soundkarte genauso auf, wie du einen Fall öffnen würdest. Das ist super einfach und noch deutlich einfacher, als jetzt mal eben kurz sich so einen Treiber zusammenzustricken.
Das wäre noch die andere Möglichkeit. Und da unter Audio liegt es. Ich hatte schon unter Port versucht, da irgendwie mal was draus schlaut zu werden in Dokumentationen, weil Leipzig ja auch dieses Port, da wollte ich die Ports wieder direkt ansprechen von der Soundkarte, aber...
Guck dir doch mal ANSA aus. ANSA ist dieses... ALSA. ALSA ist dieses Advanced Linux Sound Archive.
Das macht du einfach auf mit Open. Und dann kannst du mit IOControl, IOCtl auf dem offenen File noch so Sachen wie die Samplingrate und so weiter und sofort einstellen. Dann kannst du einfach mit Read rauslesen. Und kannst ja auch zu Freshmeet gehen. Also freshmeet.net ist die Webseite, wo es relativ viel Linux-Software gibt. Da gibt es eine ganze Abteilung Sound-Programme. Da gibt es auch einfache Programme zum Aufnehmen von Soundfiles. Und die einfach mal angucken, wie die das machen.
Und dann hatte eigentlich mit dem Gedanken gespielt, da eben ein Programm, weil diese Option ja, diese Möglichkeit da gibt, Programme im Hintergrund zu laufen, laufen zu lassen, dass der dann immer die Soundkarte auslöst und dann meinen anderen Programm immer da wieder.
Und eine FIFO auszulesen, ist dasselbe wie ein File auszulesen. Das ist dasselbe wie ein Sound-Device auszulesen. Dieser Schritt ist überflüssig.
Naja, aber wenn ich jetzt hier die Werte muss, ich alle zu einer bestimmten Zeit abholen.
Ja, die werden halt gebuffert und irgendwann ist der Buffer voll und dann finde ich die Samples.
Ach so, dieses Audio macht das aber auch schon. Noch eine Frage kurz. Trefft ihr euch morgen?
Ja, morgen ist es auf.
Wunderbar, bin halt nämlich geplant, vorbeizukommen.
Ist das was auch andere Leute interessieren könnte? Ja, gibt es Coil?
Na ja, was heißt Insider? Das ist halt unser offener Donnerstag, wenn ihr zum CCCD kommt. Ist halt nett.
Ist bei euch?
Ist wo? CCC Berlin, Marienstraße 11. www.cccde.de Genau.
So, jetzt gibt es noch eine Rückfrage. Martin ist wieder dran. Dann hat sich wahrscheinlich jetzt Linux aus dem Netz geholt. Noch nicht. Aber du hast eine Frage dazu, zur Installation.
Ja, einmal bei FreeBSD. Gibt es da auch irgendwie so Konfigurationstools wie Yast oder sowas?
Nee, gibt es nicht.
Eigentlich widersprechen Konfigurationstools der Philosophie von UNIX.
Wie gesagt, abgesehen von einigen kommerziellen Tools, die wirklich sehr ausgewachsen sind, funktionieren die meisten Sachen eben nicht. Der Charme von UNIX ist geändert. Es ist alles relativ transparent, wenn man da erst mal anfängt, sich mit zu beschäftigen. Diese Konfigurationstools sind immer sehr beschränkt in dem, was sie tatsächlich zu leisten vermögen.
Bei Duse fand ich interessant, dass man erstmal, wenn man einschaltet, dann nimmt man Konfigurationstools, aber hat trotzdem noch die Möglichkeit, sich nach und nach in die Grundlagen durchzuarbeiten. Bei FriBSD Ewer werden die dann schon von vorne reinzusperren. Zum Beispiel die Webmaster von unserer Uni, die sperren sie auf Slackware, Linux und dann haben sie mir dann einmal mal empfohlen und ich hab probiert zu installieren. Das war der absolute Hau, aber die ganzen Pfade waren völlig anders als bei Duse und irgendwie war es eine völlig ungewohnte Umgebung.
Jeder muss sich da irgendwie seine eigene Umgebung schaffen, wenn du mit Duse zufrieden bist.
Ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, ungewohner, Ja, ich kann das alles auch alles komplett rauslöschen, neu reinschreiben. Und man kann sich das auch gar nicht so strukturieren, wie man das möchte. Man ist vorgeschrieben, diese Menüs zu verwenden, kann es nicht so aufteilen, wie man das gerne will und so weiter und so fort. Also die Konfigurationsfalls sind eigentlich ein viel direkteres Interfacesystem. Es ist nun mal so, dass Computer in Text programmiert werden und nicht in Grafik. Und alles, was man in Grafik macht, hält einem vom System ab.
Wir reden gleich weiter über UNIX, um die Probleme. Ihr könnt weiterhin anrufen, wartet vielleicht noch drei Minuten. Oder 0331 70 97 1 1 0. Hier gibt es gleich erstmal die neuesten Nachrichten. Das Chaosradio auf Fritz geht gleich weiter.
Wenn Fritz in Angermünde einigen können, dieser Streitpunkt findet mir die Bildung einer Provinzregierung. Gräueltat. Deutsche Kafosoldaten haben in einem Dorf in der Nähe von Priserin die Leichen von 78 Menschen gefunden. Die Toten sind offenbar Opfer eines Massakas. Derzeit untersuchen Experten des Hager Kriegsverbrechertribunals das Gebiet. Protest. Rund 250 Kurden haben in Berlin die Freilassung des zum Tode verurteilten PKK-Führers Öcalan gefordert. Die Demonstration in der Straße unter den Linden in unmittelbarer Nähe der Außenstelle der US-Botschaft verlief ohne Zwischenfälle. Pilotabschluss. Die Beschäftigten der Desperliner Einzelhandels erhalten ab August 3% mehr Lohn und Gehalt. Darauf einigten sich am Abend die Arbeitgeber mit den Gewerkschaften HBV und DAG.
Wir fahren ganz ruhig und sinnig, wie sie das gehört, und deswegen können wir auch darauf verzichten, hier entscheidende Jingles einzuspielen. Vielen Dank, Falk. Und viel Spaß weiterhin mit den Anrufern. Falk schreibt mir nämlich immer auf, was die Leute eigentlich wollen. So, mittlerweile haben wir es... Wo habe ich denn das Ding, was ich jetzt hier abdrücken muss? Mittlerweile haben wir es 0.33, 3 Minuten nach halb eins.
Die Party von Freitag abends Montag früh mit Laurent Gagnier, DJ Hell, Karl Kraig, Taler2XLC, Mark Spuh, Marcos Lopez und Tom Wax.
50 Stunden im Fritz Love Radio.
Noch ein halbes Stündchen haben wir hier im Chaosradio an diesem wunderschönen dunklen Mittwochabend, wo es ging schon zweieinhalb Stunden über das Betriebsbetriebssystem UNIX. Ihr könnt weiterhin anrufen oder euch unter www.fritz.de in den WeChat einschalten, wo ihr auch auf HansCR40 trifft.
Chaosradio 40, wir haben ja auch irgendwie schon, wir haben immer noch ein paar, das sind schon einige. Wir haben auch die meisten der alten Sendungen mittlerweile als MPEG, aber aus Gründen ich euch lieber nicht erkläre. Wir sind immer noch nicht auf dem Server. Auf dem Camp-Wendig auf jeden Fall zu haben sein. Und wir hoffen, dass wir die auch bald irgendwie auf den Server heben können.
Auch die Aufgabe 40 wird es morgen wieder als MPEG-Fall geben bei uns. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer. Und man muss ein bisschen länger warten. Und deswegen darf man nicht so schnell auflegen. Simon hat angerufen. Hallo Simon.
Hallo, guten Morgen.
Guten Morgen.
Eigentlich ist es schon wieder morgen.
Morgen ist es erst, wenn man geschlafen hat.
Hast du schon geschlafen?
Es ist sehr stark darunter, dass es schon sehr alt ist und irrsinnig viel Ballast von Xenix und von dieser Irrung der Open Bewegung und Jena belastet ist. Dadurch hast du halt ein ziemliches Chaos. Und insofern würde ich für den Anfang eigentlich eher Linux oder BSD oder irgendwas empfehlen, was ein bisschen, ein bisschen, sag ich mal, handlicher ist. Also SCO UNIX ist mehr so ein kommerzielles UNIX, wenn man irgendwie bestimmte Steuerberater Software laufen lassen möchte oder so.
Kein Sauce Code. Also es ist langweilig, weil du hast da einfach kein Sauce Code dabei. Und das ist der eigentliche Spaß, irgendwas zu entdecken, wie es funktioniert und dann auch mal nachzuschauen, wie es denn tatsächlich gemacht ist.
Da ist auch noch ein bisschen was von Legato dabei und von Xopen.
Ja, Legato ist Backup Software. Na, es ist halt so kommerzielle Sachen, macht nicht so viel Spaß, würde ich sagen. Also, und gerade von den kommerziellen Unixen machen andere auch mehr Spaß als SCO oder der Linse.
Wo hast denn das Zeug her, wenn du nicht weißt, was drin ist?
Ich habe mein Praktikum gemacht und die hatten CDs dort rumliegen und da konnte ich mir welche mitnehmen.
So kommt man zu den CD-ROMs. Simon, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Okay, danke schön.
Mach's gut. Hallo Martin.
Ich habe eine Frage, die vielleicht nicht nur UNIX betrifft, sondern auch im Prinzip ja alle Betriebssysteme. Du hast ja viel von Internet geredet und was vor den Nachrichten gesagt wurde. Ich arbeite auch irgendwie die Verbindung zum Modem oder zur ISDN-Karte. Wie funktioniert das in den Browsern? Braucht man da einen Treiber, der im Hintergrund läuft?
Die Browser haben damit sowieso erst mal nichts zu tun.
Ja, das ist klar, die Browser zeigen ja nur die HTML-Seiten an.
Genau, du musst also das Netzwerk von den Betriebssystemen, das unter dem Browser drunterliegt, konfigurieren. Das ist natürlich bei jedem verschieden. Nee, der fragt nicht das Netzwerk ab, sondern er hat eine definierte Schnittstelle, mit der er auf das Netzwerk zugreift. Und das Netzwerk musst du aber im Betriebssystem konfigurieren. Du könntest ja noch ein anderes Programm haben, das Internetdienste verwende, wie zum Beispiel ein Mail-Reader oder ein Telnet oder irgendetwas anderes. Und das will ja auch auf das Netzwerk zugreifen. Und deswegen gibt es da eine standardisierte Schnittstelle, über die wir das alles machen. Darunter macht ein Sourcecode einen Funktionsaufruf, so ein Socket. Dann wird ein Socket erzeugt und dann sagt er Connect und dann verbindet der die Verbindung, die TCP-IP-Verbindung. Und auf welches Gerät das zugreift, ob es auf ein Modem oder eine Netzwerkkarte oder eine ISDN-Karte usw. zugreift. Das macht das Betriebssystem. Dafür ist ein Betriebssystem ja auch zuständig, dich von der Hardware, die da drunter liegt, zu abstrahieren. Genau dasselbe wie mit der Soundkarte. Warum soll man da irgendwie auf den IO-Ports rumspielen? Man macht einfach DevDSP auf und ganz egal, welche Soundkarte das ist, es funktioniert einfach.
War das geklärt soweit?
Hört sich gut an, ja.
So, siehst du, gleich ransetzen und ausprobieren. Schöne Nacht noch dann.
Und da sollte dann irgendwie Matlab drauf gefahren werden und es sollte dann auch mal ein neues AX drauf gemacht werden. War so ein altes 32 sollte 42 drauf. Und dann haben wir uns bemüht. Ich hab das Ding ja auch geerbt und hab vorher mit UNIX so nie was zu tun gehabt. Und auf jeden Fall bei IBM angerufen und die sagen dann ja, welche Kiste ist das denn? Die kennen jede Kiste persönlich genau. Die haben ja Nummern, diese RISC-Station. Und ja, dann war die erste Auskunft AX42 kostet 5000 Mark. Also das war für uns viel zu teuer. Da kriegst du ja zwei PCs mit Linux. Also wurde irgendwie gesagt, das machen wir denn nicht. Dann riefen die nochmal an und meinten, das wäre doch wohl eine Campus-Lizenz möglich. Die kostet nur 200. Ja, die dürfen sie doch jetzt. Ihr habt ja Geld bezahlt, ihr dürft das jetzt kopieren. Ja wie denn? Wo denn? Wo gibts denn die? Ja, besorgen sich die doch irgendwo. Ich sag ja, wie denn? Ja, sie werden doch wohl irgendwen kennen, der diese CDs hat. Dann haben wir dann erfahren, dass das Rechenzentrum bei uns die vorhält. Und dann durften wir uns die da abholen und selbst noch kopieren. Also Geld hatten wir bezahlt und dann durften wir die endlich mal kopieren. Ja und dann gab es die nächste große Pleite, denn du brauchst ja nämlich einen ganz wichtigen Schlüssel. Du kannst diese Kisten nämlich überhaupt nicht booten von CD, wenn du diesen Schlüssel nicht hast. Da ist ja so ein Schalter dran, so ein Wartungs-Schalter. Und wenn du den nicht auf Wartung umlegen kannst, dann macht die einfach gar nichts, die Kiste. Die läuft einfach nur vor sich hin und bootet nicht. Als er geknackt war und diese CD darauf verklagt, dann konnte man endlich mal einen 4.2 booten. Na ja, und vorhin hattet ihr ja auch diesen Smith angesprochen. Also da muss ich auch sagen, weil ich da auch ins kalte Wasser gesprungen bin, das ist eigentlich ein nettes Tool. Da kann man sehr gut mitarbeiten. Also wer keine Ahnung von UNIX hat und das Ding vorfindet, der hat eigentlich schon ganz gut gewonnen.
Ja, das Problem bei diesen Konfigurationstools ist ja auch, dass sie alle anders sind. Also man kann bei jedem UNIX mit dem Befehl if-config seine IP-Adresse einstellen, mit dem Befehl root, seine Router einstellen und dann hat man Internet. Und die Konfigurationstools sind halt alle anders. Das heißt, die Konfigurationstools muss man jedes Mal neu lernen. Sonst hingegen, wenn man sich irgendwann mal angeguckt hat, wie das da drunter funktioniert, kommt man eigentlich überall klar.
Klar, das machst du mit der X, das scheint ja wohl auch ein richtiges UNIX zu sein, aber Linux kenne ich nicht halt. Aber durch diese Spezial-Hardware, die du da vorfindest von IBM, ist das natürlich doch schon ein ganz schöner Aufstand, den du da machen musst. Und da kostet auch ein SIM-Modul, auch ein Vielfaches von so einem Modul, was du hier für ein PC mal kurz nachrüstest. Das ist also schon irgendwie ein bisschen Spezial-Hardware. So ganz glücklich sind wir da auch nicht mit, weil du heute eben halt so ein Standard-PC für kleine Mark kriegst und da ein Linux drauf fahren kannst.
Vor allem diese alte Hardware, die hat halt auch den Nachteil, dass sie langsam ist. Und das ist dann schon die Frage, ob man bereit ist, bloß weil man dann AIX laufen lassen kann, doch wirklich deutlich länger zu warten.
Nee, aber was man sagen muss, ist, mein Kollege macht da, du kannst also wirklich als zweiter, dritter, vierter User mit der Konsole drauf arbeiten. Du merkst das natürlich in einer Geschwindigkeit, aber das Ding läuft absolut zuverlässig.
Na ja, schussfest sind diese Systeme. Die wären auch gern bei Polizei und Feuerwehr eingesetzt, solche IBM-Computer, die dann auch, wie gesagt, diese Schlüsselnummer ist ja so eine ganz typische Wir schaffen Vertrauen.
Wir haben da eine Weile gebastelt.
Okay, Bert, vielen Dank. Viel Spaß noch an dieser Nacht.
Ich fühle mich immer wieder beeindruckt, wenn Leute feststellen, dass es Computer gibt, die nicht abstürzen. Wahnsinn. Nachdem sich das mit dem UNIX alles so stabilisiert hatte, oder RAM nachgesteckt wird, oder aus irgendeinem Grund, und nicht weil es abstürzt.
Schön. Axel ist dran.
Ich habe hier einen kleinen Buchtipp, das ist aber nicht ein Prinzip für Anfänger, sondern eher was für die Leute, die sich mit den Grundkonzepten von UNIX ein bisschen vertraut machen wollen. Das ist ein Schinken, der mir schon vor ein paar Jahren begegnet ist. Erst in der Uni und später auch privat heiß geliebt. Und zwar ist das von Samuel Leffer und Marcia Nacuzic das Buch mit dem schönen Titel das 4.3 BSP UNIX-Betriebssystem Design und Implementierung. Und ja, ich meine, auch wenn da so die aktuellen Sachen, also aktuelle Probleme, die man so mit einem täglichen Linux betrifft.
Der Auflage von das ist, das gibt jetzt eben The Design and Implementation of the 4.4 BSD Operating System. Das ist das rote Buch mit dem Teufel drauf und das kann ich auch wärmstens als Nachfolger empfehlen.
Ja, das ist mir entgegen, entfallen oder mehr oder weniger durch die Lappen gegangen. Weil als Anekdote, wie ich zum Linus gekommen bin, das liegt eher daran, dass mein damals angeschaffter 386er technisches KUO erlag, in der Zeit, wo das FreeBSD festhing, aus lizenztechnischen Gründen. Und so stand der Rechner in der Ecke und das Buch wurde dann auch nicht mehr benutzt. Das wurde also von mir alles angeschafft in Erwartung von FreeBSD. Das ist übrigens auch ein hübscher Vorteil von Linux. Die meiste Zeit, die ich auf Arbeit übrig habe, die übrig bleibt bei den normalen täglichen Dingen, ist dann im Keller alte Hardware zusammenklauben und daraus nette Router waskeln. Also wenn man auch Angst hat vom Konfigurieren eines Lerungssystems, das macht man einmal und dann laufen die Kisten. Und das läuft halt auch auf alter Hardware. Und auch wenn man sich so was wie einen kleinen Prinzbuhler oder so eine Sache, einen Drucker, den man nur mit paralleler Schnittstelle hat und den hängt man ins Netz mit irgendeinem kleinen 386er, der nur von Floppy bootet. Solche Sachen kann man wunderbar damit basteln.
Und das Schöne ist, dass man immer mit Tainet drauf geht.
Das war eine alte MX-2. Das ist ein Berliner Satzunternehmen, Satzrechenzentrum. Mal ein bisschen Davons machen. Nein, nein, aber es ist eine Druckvorstufe. Und wir haben also auch noch einen BS2000 da, so richtig geil. Aber auch hat sich Linux wieder bewährt. Es ist verdammt schwierig, so ein Zoo an Betriebssystemen, also vom BS2000 über BadgeStats, über Suns bis hin zu Macs und PCs, wo es ja mittlerweile auch Freimaker und solche Sachen ordentlich drauf gibt, die alle unter einen Hut zu bringen. Also mit dem Fileserver oder so, dass man halbwegs die Dokumente untereinander scheren kann, ist nicht so einfach.
Man muss es konfigurieren, aber wenn es dann mal läuft, dann ist es echt effizient.
Also man richtet es ein und es läuft. Zum Punkt Einrichtung habe ich, weiß nicht ob euch sowas mal begegnet ist, vor ungefähr zehn Jahren habe ich mit Motorola-Kisten angefangen zu arbeiten und die haben das sehr schön gelöst. Da gab es ja damals noch keine grafischen Oberflächen, also wenigstens nicht in dem Sektor. Die haben einen privilegierten Account gehabt namens SysAdmin und haben alle Aufgaben, die täglichen Aufgaben eines Administrators in Form von Shellscripten zusammengefasst. Also der normale Mensch konnte sich dann über diese Menüsysteme durchhangeln und konnte seine Konfiguration vornehmen. Und der Fortgeschrittene, der konnte kurzerhand in die Shellscripten reingucken und nachforschen, wie geht das eigentlich? Das ist etwas, was wir das anbieten, aber ich lerne dabei nichts.
Ja, das ist nicht transparent. Da hast du dann irgendwie ganz tolle Oberfläche.
Bei Yast, das geht gerade noch so. Da gibt es ja dann die rc.config, wo Yast ja alles reinschreibt, was es so tut. Und dann auch jede Menge Scripte, die von Yast ausgeführt werden, wenn irgendwas geändert wird. Und auch in die Scripte kann man eigentlich reingucken, sich angucken, was passiert da eigentlich ist. Natürlich schon eine ganz schöne Menge Code, die man sich da angucken muss, um das alles zu verstehen. Aber es geht auch schon noch.
Also ich habe mich jetzt vor ungefähr zwei Tagen die Platze geärgert über Red Hat. Da sie ja mittlerweile auch versuchen, mit Druck das Linux-Kompte reinzubringen, damit die normalen Leute, damit in Anführungszeichen alle Leute mit umgehen können, haben sie da auch die ganzen RC Bootskripte umgeschrieben. Und überall ein IF-Distance entdeckt. Ja, ist auf dem System. Aber das habe ich natürlich nicht benutzt.
Ich weiß, wann das noch für Zeiten als es RC gab und rc.net und rc.local und das war's.
Genau, da geht man rein und da nimmt man sich den VI, der Freund von dem RfS-Administrator.
Der VI, dass wir den heute noch nicht erwähnt haben.
Diesen tollen Editor, das ist eigentlich eine Schande.
Ja, der ist prima.
Ich meine, es gibt ja auch so hübsche Hilfen dafür.
Ja, aber pass auf, der VI, weißt du, als Computeranwender, wenn du so interaktive Computer von heute kennst, erwartest du nicht, dass du den Editor startest, den System-Editor. Und wenn du eine Taste drückst, dann piept er. Und wenn du es dann schaffst, irgendwie ihn dazu zu bringen, dass er deine Tastendrücke auch irgendwie annimmt, dann kann er das machen.
Wenn dein Bildschirm kaputt ist, weil du einfach mit dem VI kontextorientiert vorgehst, und manchmal war das einfach mal die Rettung.
Na gut, dann muss man dann ED benutzen, wenn man kein Video hat.
Man muss auch entschuldigen dazu sagen, dass VI aus der Zeit kommt, also es ist auch ein völlig neues Konzept, aber die Datei, die man editiert, auch gleichzeitig angezeigt zu bekommen.
Ich meine, UNIX fing an mit Druckerturbinismus. Da gab es so was wie ein Bildschirm.
Ja, er hat sich aber auch deutlich weiterentwickelt, also wenigstens im freien Sektor. Also SIM als Editor an sich ist ja nicht konfigurierbar. Und zur Not kann man ihn auch so hinbiegen, dass er so ein körsertastenorientierter Mensch ist.
Aber eben genau diese andere UNIX-Linie beschreibend gibt es von Maurice J. Bach das Buch Design of the UNIX Operating System. Bei Prentice Hall ist das rausgekommen. Das ist im Prinzip die System V-Bibel. Also dieser MacEusek war halt irgendwie die BSD-Bibel. Und das ist sozusagen das zugehörige Buch auf der anderen Linie.
Ich gucke gerade, ich glaube, der Bach steht bei mir in der zweiten Reihe.
Ein sehr schönes Buch. Also ich habe es sehr genossen und es bringt einen guten Blick.
Axel hat wahrscheinlich 3 Millionen UNIX-Betriebssystem-Erklärungsbücher.
Man braucht gar nicht so viele. Man braucht eigentlich immer nur die paar richtigen Bücher. Das ist alles, was man braucht. Man muss nicht so viel lesen.
Also wer die Buchtipps nochmal hat...
Ich habe angefangen, so eine Bücher zu, na nicht sammeln, aber wenn man mal eins gefunden hat, setzt du glaube ich auf Minix auf.
Wir sollten nochmal auf unsere Mailing-Liste hinweisen, wo wir eventuell Buchtipps nochmal posten. Man kann sich da eintragen. Und jetzt kommt die Adresse von Tim.
www.ccc.de und dann slash ticker, oder?
Wir haben ja noch die Homepage von Chaosradio. Chaosradio.ccc.de, da könnt ihr mal nachgucken. Chaosradio.ticker ist halt eine Announce-Mailing-Liste, wo man sich eintragen kann, wo wir auch immer die nächste Sendung ankündigen und so weiter. Und da versuchen wir dann auch immer Feedback zu senden.
Wenn wir dich gerade mal wieder von...
Du kannst uns ja vielleicht auch mal deine Bücherliste schicken, was du so im Schrank zu stehen hast.
Genau, die toasten wir dann gerne. Überhaupt schickt uns mehr Feedback.
Was mich so ein bisschen immer irritiert, ist das Installationsversuchen. Ja, ich weiß nicht so, was man davon halten soll. Ich beobachte das eher mit Sorge. Also ein gutes Buch, mal jetzt abgesehen davon, dass man sich da auch ein bisschen detaillierter fortbilden kann, als mit einer Zeitschrift, wo nur drin steht jetzt irgendwie die CD ein, und BOOTEN, die BUMMS haben die KDE vor der Nase.
Naja, bloß ich meine, das Ausprobieren ist natürlich auch eine sehr wertvolle Geschichte. Klar muss man sich auch informieren, wie es tatsächlich funktioniert, aber Ausprobieren ist in jedem Fall...
Ja, das Buch geht schon ein bisschen weiter. Und wenn ich dann ausprobiere und ich stöße auf ein Problem, dann wird mir da auch geholfen, in der Zeitschrift in der Regel nicht.
Ja, das ist klar. Naja, aber besser, in der Zeitschrift wird erklärt, dass das ganz einfach ist, und dann probieren wir...
Vielen Dank, Axel, eine schöne Nacht noch. Ilja, du sprichst jetzt bitte schön das Schusswort. Darfst du dich jetzt einmal ausheulen, als auf der Party in der Ecke stehender?
Ich wollte dir noch erzählen, wie glorrecht und mich selbst stolzmachend es mir gelungen ist, auf meinem alten Mac 2CX vor ungefähr drei Monaten diese M68K-BSD-Film zu installieren. Das war nämlich gar nicht so leicht, weil A, die Dokumentation war falsch, irgendwie der Teilnahme haben nicht gestimmt.
Und wahrscheinlich brauchtest du noch eine andere Ethernet-Karte, weil genau die, die drin war, nicht richtig unterstützt wurden.
Nein, doch, die wurde unterstützt, aber das Aufspülen des Fightesteams hat dermaßen tierisch lange gedauert. Das ist ein Informatiker und ein Paar, der sozial ausgegrenzt ist.
Das ist ein sozial-kritisches Thema.
Genau, ich habe auch die Erfahrung, nachts um halb zwei klingelte Telefon und irgendwelche Mädchen rufen an und denken so, naja, so ein armer Informatiker und so, der ist ja nie bestimmt unserem Tipp verlegen, wenn er dann am nächsten Morgen vielleicht ein Dächeln dafür erntet. Kennt er so einen Schoten wie halb zwei klingelt? Du, ich habe jetzt einen 286er mit Windows 3.1 geschenkt gekriegt. Das heißt, ich habe erst mal 10 Minuten gebraucht, um rauszukriegen, was das überhaupt für eine Kiste ist. Und beim Drucken kommt dann nur so Klötzchen-Texte. Die Bewerbung muss bis morgen stehen. Ich bin Mac-User, aber das interessiert irgendwie andere Menschen gar nicht. Was du jetzt privat machst, du bist Informatiker, das heißt, du musst das können. Oder ja, die einen Ruf haben, naja, Informatiker und Frauen sind nicht gerade so, naja, die Sachen, die sich vertragen. Und dann gezielt probieren, Scheine zu machen, indem sie sich irgendeinen armen Gericht suchen, sich, naja, ein bisschen näher an ihn ransetzen in der Vorlesung. Nicht ganz nah, aber so nur einen Platz Abstand. Und dass er ihnen dann die Hausabgaben macht und...
Ah, Billigdiplom, naja, so ist das.
Wenn ich auch schon hinterhätt ich.
Das war doch bei den Bandis auch so. Wie viel ist 9x5? Ah, ich weiß, am Montag den kurzen Rock anziehen.
Genau, der lauert die Tücke nicht nur in der CPU, sondern auch auf ganz anderen Gebieten.
Ja, der Beifall der hier anwesenden ebenfalls Computermächtigen ist hier sicher.
Aber ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, der Nutzer in der Frauenanteil doch deutlich besser wird und auch Frauen, die etwas wissen und verstehen, deutlich mehr werden. So ist es zum Beispiel für die Userbetreuung in der C-Base eine Frau verantwortlich, um den Neujusern zu erklären, wie das mit der Mail funktioniert. Also es wird alles gut. Vielen Dank, Stefan.
Euch noch eine schöne Nacht. Normalerweise hauen wir uns bei Chaosradio nämlich die Köppe ein.
Nun sei mal ruhig bitte, Tim, ja? Okay, wir wollen es jetzt hier nicht zerstören. Denkt an den Termin 6. bis 8. August. Geht auf die Chaosradio-Seiten oder auf die Chaoscomputer-Seiten und meldet euch an für das Camp Altlandsberg, kosten 130 Mark, wenn man sich voran meldet. Die Ausgabe 41 wird dann irgendwann wieder über den Chaosradio-Ticker wahrscheinlich angekündigt. Viel Spaß in der Nacht, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.